Oh,
here we go.
You dirty bitches a certain point in time,
I'm going to run out of dirty bitches.
He can only call people dirty bitches
so many before he'd come like a form of
self parody,
but it hasn't reached that point yet.
I don't know.
It'll,
I'll know when it's there.
You know?
It's like that saying that was cool and
then all of a sudden it's like you'll be
sponsored by dove soap and then
you won't be able to say it.
And it's like,
do you remember when that
fuck you song came out?
Yeah.
See it green.
That song was fucking
amazing when it came out.
I mean that dude's like harmonious
voice and you know saying,
fuck you.
You know what everybody really wants to
say when you get your heart ripped out
of your chest.
I need to drive it around town.
Another dude's driving around town
with the girl you love and you're like,
fuck you.
But then somewhere along the line
they talk to that dude in the change,
in the words to forget,
you know,
that's just the radio part.
It doesn't matter when they
talked to him and to doing that,
a little piece of the world died.
They,
there's a song called
turned into a mall,
a little piece of the world that not
even the mall that Santa's set up at the
mall where there's like the stupidest
looking fake fucking snow on the ground
and a little wooden fucking fake deer.
Like don't even try and like,
they're not really trying to trick you.
They're like sort of represents Sanas
workshop and this stupid dude pretending
to be sick.
That's what it became
where it was raw and real.
I'm like,
fuck you.
Yeah,
And he's like,
I'm like,
forget you what?
There's this song called thrift shop and
they have to edit it just like that for
the radio and but it,
they edited so much stupid things like
the edit honky out the word Honky,
I'm offended by that word or that you
smell like or it smells like r Kelly's
pis.
They edited that out.
I wish we could elevate
Beta honky to the level of nigger.
I wish we could have a word that was
just as effective for a black person.
Do you?
So it would be an even war
because of the way it is now.
It's like us versus
Yugoslavia or something.
You know what I mean?
Like some small country that
doesn't have nuclear weapons,
like the amount of power
that the United States has,
it's ridiculous for them
to try to hurl their,
their weaponry,
our way.
We'll verbally,
that's what it is.
White to black cause niggers,
the ultimate nuclear weapon.
It's like you're gonna fight.
Someone's going to fight you.
They will beat the fuck out
of you for using that word.
There's no white equivalent.
It doesn't even exist.
There's no white equivalent,
no dehumanizing white equivalent.
You know,
like the,
the,
the idea of saying that word.
It's like a,
it dehumanizes people because
the guy slavery connotations.
A Mazda Gotti though,
she said that is a deep inside NMH.
Okay.
Um,
that's Adam.
That's Adam Hunter ways.
Gentlemen.
This podcast has a couple of sponsors.
She fucking get those out of the way.
But we did an already,
we already started a real podcast.
Maybe it's better this way for us.
Maybe,
maybe you won't feel so bad
that we talk about sponsors.
Um,
the only thing that will promise and,
uh,
always and if were incorrect about this,
we'll,
we'll let you know,
um,
is that anything that
we get involved with,
we believe is a legitimate con company
that's trying to sell you good shit.
We're not really interested in selling
you something that's useless and we're
not interested in
selling you bad products.
And I was having a conversation online
today with someone who is upset about one
of our sponsors and that
that sponsor is ting.
This guy's an idiot.
But the con,
the conversation was so dumb.
Um,
one of the things he was mad at is that
it's on the sprint's network is a CDMA
network and so he can't
use the phone overseas.
And I'm like,
well that's just because it's,
it's,
it's a,
it's a sprint network.
That's what it is.
It's an American network.
Like there's only two American
networks that are CDMA,
that's Verizon and sprint.
And you can't use those overseas.
If you want to use Verizon overseas,
you have to have a,
um,
a,
a dual country card.
You have to have a GSM
chip inside the phone.
So it has essentially
as to two radios in it.
So when you're overseas
it kicks in the GSM one,
it becomes a world phone.
Does he live overseas and or does he
just travel in your lives overseas?
But he's in America I guess.
And he was upset that he can't take it
with them to his control over the roof.
Fucking read it dude.
If you're in a,
you're a specialized situation for
someone in America wants to like talk to
people from America,
you can call other countries from here.
It's an awesome service.
So be aware of that.
There's I,
there's only a few countries
that still use CDMA,
which is interesting because apparently
CDMA is like the older technology,
but it goes deeper into
buildings apparently.
That's why a lot of people that
say they have Verizon and sprint,
they,
they will say that they get better
coverage than people who have GSM.
They have like at and.
T.
I find it,
see him,
at least in La.
CDMA is definitely better
for like not dropping calls.
That's what I thought.
You don't know about that.
You're,
you're okay.
I have,
well I have a 18 t iPhone
five and then I have a Ipad,
uh,
Verizon,
right.
My Shit,
at least their data network.
I can never get fucking
data on my fucking iPad.
But then I look at my other phone,
I'm like,
oh,
I couldn't make a hotspot on my at t
and t networks on my Verizon iPad will
work.
Did you do that and was it more effective?
Yeah.
So you think that data is more
effective than what region?
It just seems like it just seems like
where in La that it's the at and t is
pretty solid in la now.
Like you're in Texas,
you're probably running around
on cricket or something.
Seemed like it was,
I used a t for a while and then when I
switched over to Verizon I noticed a big
difference.
I thought it was much better.
And I find that the same places that
I could make calls with Verizon,
I can pretty much make calls with sprint,
seems to be,
at least in the of the
issue places that I had,
you know,
I,
but as far as like a data networks,
those data networks are those,
those are funky man.
Let's fucking online like four g
laptop chips that you put in your,
you know,
those are a little wonky,
like don't be trying to
download anything big,
you know,
don't be thinking you're really online.
You're on some weird thing that's like
sorta online but it's not really online.
And if you have you get frisky,
it'll fucking kick you off.
You know,
look at this dude tried
to download a movie,
bitch the fuck out of here.
There's disconnect you tingling
and do that then not like that.
They're nice.
Uh,
the,
this is the criticism that this guy
had said in a forum and then not to,
you know,
make his point like,
uh,
any,
bigger or grander than it was.
But he,
the idea was that Ting
wasn't a non he evil company.
I think it's forum posts said,
stop saying that Ting
is a non evil company,
that they're evil for having
CDMA and I guess maybe they,
they do something with the,
the operating system to sprint,
do something.
I know they put their own brand on it,
but I think the whole thing that people
love about android phones apparently is
that if you really want
to get crazy with them,
you can jailbreak.
I'm like super easy.
He can route them or whatever it is.
I know somebody that just made their
phone look like a exactly like it's a
windows seven phone or eight phone.
I'm like,
ah,
that's,
that's horrible.
Don't ever show that to me.
I know you can do weird
stuff with those androids.
That's one of the things.
Yeah,
I die.
I can't get involved with that.
I can't be fucking around
what it comes with.
That's what I'm going to keep.
I really don't have the time,
but I do appreciate that it's available
to people that want to do that kind of
shit.
If you're one of them.
Hack sores type dudes that likes to
get in your phone and fuck around.
I used to be like that.
I think I'd be at an android
user if I was 10 years ago.
If you go to [inaudible] dot tv.com
you can save 25 bucks off of,
uh,
off of,
any phone or service or
a credit device discount,
25 bucks.
But prisons,
you previously it was a
$50 device discount and now
you can apply the $25 total
discount to either the service or towards
a new device if you go to and the dot
[inaudible] dot com but you said you
can still find it for 50 bucks online.
Hey,
check out this,
just Google ting review and
just go to the first line.
And then they have a really
nice write up of Ting and it's,
you know,
cuts through through it and there might
be a thing that you can click on and be
able to get $50 off.
Welcome to tinker with that
promotion code from our partner.
You get $50 off many
devices and online that
am I apply this discount.
Sorry.
Rogan,
I'm Outta here,
dude.
I got shafted for 25 bucks.
They took a $25 gamble on me.
I tell you the coolest thing though about
thing is when you actually sign up for
Ting and you actually get
through the whole entire process,
they have a new,
a different drawing and like they have
these weird drawings on tanning Jesus.
No,
that's bringing in Walsh,
I think.
I think he's crying.
No,
no.
Brian Walsh doesn't cry.
Jesus Christ.
That's teases him.
But,
but like when you sign up,
there's like this really hot chick and
she's like jumping up and down type
thing.
So really?
Yeah.
So it's the only way you can see
it is if you actually sign up.
Hmm.
Oh,
that's ridiculous.
Why not just show me the pictures?
Why?
Why don't you fucking play games?
Um,
what,
what we like about Ting,
first of all,
there's a,
there's no contracts or ETF.
What does ETFs?
Probably electronic.
Yeah.
What does that mean?
It says no contracts or ETFs.
Should we know what that means?
Truly.
Incompletely contract free.
No early termination fees.
Oh,
early termination fees.
So you don't have early termination
fees when you cancel your cell phones.
Like if you can't see your contract,
if you a three year contract,
you have to pay you all the money.
Uh,
no bundling or riding along services.
And so they have,
um,
no overage charges or penalties.
If you use more than
you thought you would,
you just pay for what you used.
You also get credits on unused service.
This is where it's crazy.
If you use a less than
you thought you would,
tank drops you down to the level you hit
and then credits you the difference on
your next bill.
You can't say that that's
a non evil company.
You can't,
you can't argue with that.
That's a good deal.
That sounds like a company that is
interested in selling you exactly what you
need and are going to use as opposed
to locking you in some sort of stupid
situation that you're,
you're probably never going to fully
use and you're going to get stuck.
You're going to get stuck there.
And if you want to get out,
you've got to pay.
Um,
so we like him.
We like what they're doing.
We liked the,
the thought behind it.
And if you've got a rogan.ting.com and
save 25 bucks or go to that other dude
say 50,
if that's your shit,
but just go get some tanks,
get some in your life about their opinion.
Get some to take up any new hooker.
Uh,
we're also brought to you
by [inaudible] dot com um,
makers of the hemp force,
a protein supplement
which is made out of uh,
the highest protein hemp and it's
like really fucking intense stuff.
It's my favorite protein powder.
It's all like,
it's got raw cocoa in it.
It's gotten Maka in it,
so it's got antioxidants in it.
And Makkah is supposed to do something,
something like a muscle building or the,
the idea is that it increases
testosterone or something,
I don't know at some fucking funky route,
but the combination of
them with the Stevia,
it tastes fantastic.
Um,
for two days in a row I've been
drinking this upgraded coffee stuff.
I decided I'm going to get off Starbucks.
Starbucks can socket.
All right this,
there's some funky coffee out there,
man.
If Dave Asprey's correct,
if he's saying that,
uh,
all these coffees have toxic
mold on it and that's what a,
it's slowly poisoning people and that
people were drinking mold that drinking
mold,
mold t basically while,
um,
we started carrying this stuff
and on it called upgraded coffee.
And a,
the idea behind it is
it's from a single source,
it's processed so that you know that it's
entirely mold free package sealed and
then it gets to you.
And when,
when you get coffee that's from
like a single source like this,
like real quality coffee.
It's really weird,
but you don't get like nearly
as much of a crash when,
when you're coming off of it.
And I don't understand it.
And uh,
you know,
Dave Asprey's version
of bulletproof coffee,
we're drinking it right now.
It's got a grass fed butter and MCT oil
and the coffee blended together as your
shit's been oilier.
They come both firing out
like logs on a river son boom.
But,
uh,
his,
um,
his coffee is,
uh,
the,
the combination of the MCT oil and the
grass fed butter with the coffee all
blended together.
It's crazy.
Like you,
it gives you energy for hours
and when it's over it's just,
it's,
it's much more mild,
at least for me than other coffee,
which leads to me to believe
that he might be right.
I might've been,
I might've been drinking
fungus t I might've been
drinking some moldy ask beans.
And uh,
according to that guy from
that dangerous grounds show,
apparently a large percentage
of the coffee that we get
in this country has mold
on it and that's fucking crazy.
So um,
so we immediately started carrying
that as soon as we heard about it.
And that's the kind of shit that on
it is into doing anything that we,
we start caring.
It's because either we use it and we
love it or we heard it's the best shit or
it's what people have been requesting.
Whether it's killer bee honey,
nobody was requesting killer bee honey.
Okay.
Nobody would,
why would you want to kill her honey?
Cause it's gangster as fuck to steal
some honey from some killer bees.
I'm sorry.
Even if it doesn't taste as good,
I am going to go with the
killer bee honey every time.
Cause I'm stupid like that.
All right.
And if you want some killer bee honey,
we got that shit.
This is real killer bee honey.
It's a,
I love it.
So that's the kind of shit that we
carry it on it from the hemp force.
Unfortunately we have
to buy it from Canada.
We have to buy all of our hemp protein
from Canada because cause people are
crazy.
And because hemp is the non-psychoactive
a version of the marijuana sativa
plants.
The hemp is the uh,
the,
you know,
the way it works is like you can call
them cousins or strains or now this has
been a lot of argument and
anger online about nomenclature.
But the bottom line is that the,
the hemp,
when you,
when you're,
when you're getting him
in the hemp force protein,
you're getting non psychoactive plants.
The males are non
psychoactive and the females,
uh,
the ones that you,
grow into a marijuana leaves,
you have to like separate
them from the males,
you know,
keep the males from
getting an Achy in them.
You know,
you had the like breed together.
The plants breed.
It's fascinating shit,
man.
They're,
they're,
they're literally like a sexual
plant while the hemp that we get,
we have to get in Canada,
so we can't even have a farm.
We can't even grow the
non psychoactive version.
Like you can come check,
make sure it's the right stuff.
You can't even grow that.
They,
they,
they do.
They do not want Americans
even growing it for,
uh,
for use as textiles or as a commodity.
They don't want it
introduced into the market.
It's an incredibly powerful resource.
It's one of the greatest plants on earth.
I mean,
it really is an amazing product.
If you stop and think about all the
different things that hemp does,
it really would blow your fucking mind.
And it's kind of a Hippie,
explosion,
drowning type situation
because we've all said,
we've heard people talk
about it so many times,
like especially hippies
that just like you,
June Newman and hemp has been
noonish to shrink tumors.
Did,
you knew that you can make your clothes
ahead of him and after a while he just
want to go,
okay,
you're annoying.
So I think Hampson knowing too,
I'm listening to you and I'm getting
crazy noise and I'm assuming that hemp
socks cause you suck,
well does not suck folks.
It is a craziest plant on earth.
You can make the finest paper out of
it far stronger than paper that we have
that's made out of trees.
You can make food out of it,
you can eat it.
It has essential amino acids in it.
It has protein.
You can make clothes out of it
far superior to cotton clothes.
You can turn it into fucking
heating oil to power the lamps,
these,
these hemp oil lamps.
You can take the oil and you put it on
your food and it makes your food far more
nutritious.
It's a crazy plants.
If you juice it,
you extract the juice.
Apparently it's super healthy,
like way healthier than wheat
grass juice and it's illegal.
We're so fucking stupid when it
comes to this that it hurts my brain.
But at least we can sell you
hemp force grown in Canada.
And not that I don't love given Canadians
work cause I love me some Canadians.
But that's bullshit.
It's on.
All right.
And with that said,
use the code neighbor Brogan and you will
save 10% off any and all supplements,
uh,
that,
that code does not apply to kettle
bells and battle ropes and all that shit
because a,
all that fitness equipment stuff is super
hard to ship and very hard to carry.
Like we,
we were sending these iron
balls in the mail.
Okay.
It's a,
it's a huge pain that Dick.
So the uh,
the,
the discounts on that do not apply because
we're trying to sell them to you as
cheaply as we possibly can.
The battle ropes are the cheapest.
You can find that the highest quality,
like ship yard ropes.
You ever work out with us?
Dude?
You ever do battle rope workouts?
So fun.
It's fun.
It's savage.
Re you feel like you're
like Conan or something.
Uh,
anyway,
that's it.
Use a code name,
Rogan,
10% off any supplements
and a and that's it.
You,
Fox,
Adam Hunter is here and we're going to,
we're fixing to get busy.
[inaudible] Adam,
welcome to the podcast,
sir.
It's good to be here.
Be here with you as well.
My friends and Brian Redman always.
What's up buddy?
How are you?
I'm doing great man.
This is like,
what are the highlights
of my whole career?
Not even kidding.
That's ridiculous,
but thank you.
I'm honored and it's ridiculous.
At the same time,
Adam was,
um,
uh,
really funny,
standup comedian and a,
a big MMA fan and he said
something really funny,
uh,
on Twitter.
You said it on Twitter,
right?
And,
uh,
and I,
I read it on a,
on the air and a god and a bit of trouble.
I said that,
uh,
you want to say it?
She said that Martin Kampmann comes
from behind more than Lance Bass.
Yes.
I said,
you know,
this is a distasteful jokes.
And then I said it anyway.
No,
it was great.
You gave me credit for it.
And there was a moment of just awkwardness
Kohlberg over and looked at you.
And he's like,
and it was the greatest
talking television dude.
I was on a crew.
I'm on a cruise.
I don't,
don't get Internet,
can't watch the fights,
I'm depressed.
I'm like working on a ship.
They can't.
I'm trying.
I can't get nothing,
no TVS.
And then all of a sudden I get a text,
my phone was on,
it was like,
dude,
Rogan's blew you up on Twitter,
do roving to see a come from behind joke.
And I'm like,
I don't know who won the fight.
And now I'm like looking.
I'm like,
Dude.
thank you bro.
You don't have no idea
how much that meant.
It was fucking awesome.
People said to me that that's like,
oh well like I've heard
criticism like total,
even though for the Turkey,
that is hilarious.
If you know who Martin Kampmann is and
you know like Martin Kampmann has had
some amazing come from behind victories,
so to say that he comes from
behind more than Lance Bass.
I thought that was so funny,
man.
Oh,
thank you.
I probably shouldn't
have said it on the air.
It was DePaul,
first of all,
Sam,
sons of anarchy on the
air and that network.
I mean this is the show.
This is will.
People are silly.
I mean,
I don't think they care.
It's just a joke.
And if you do care,
come on,
you just watched a guy get his fucking
face beaten in any better get to Anderson
Cooper,
it would have been just,
you know,
yeah,
that would have probably been better,
but I don't even understand
what via what the,
the would even better.
A little bit better because it feels
like you're picking on Lance Bass,
whereas Anderson Cooper feels
like he can defend himself.
People I want to know,
I went on one of those like,
uh,
forums and uh,
I know underground,
right?
And people had like pictures of lands,
Bass and that says we got your back Bro.
I was like,
dude,
that is the funniest fucking thing.
And then people were
arguing for like 30 pages,
30 pages of threads back and
forth on why someone was like,
the only thing is offensive,
uh,
as,
as a gay man is that lance bass,
assuming that he comes from behind it,
that guy's a a bottom.
Like people were like,
well,
it's not offensive.
It's not,
I mean,
what is wrong with coming?
It doesn't everybody want to come?
People are having sex.
Well,
they just want to just like try
it real quick and then stop dude.
And then someone wrote,
this is how the Holocaust started
trolling.
It's like what do people,
but I was like,
it was unbelievable.
I was like joke to everybody.
I tell everybody that choke.
It's a funny fucking joke man did.
And it's funny cause I started the MMA
roasted like about a year ago and like
literally Mike,
my page has like 5,000 followers and
then they roast it has 18 six six 17,000
followers.
Like they blew up because
people just are like,
people seem to love it.
You know,
cause they've tried to do it in a way
where it's not disrespectful but you're
still making someone laugh.
Yeah.
You will walk a fine line.
You're making fun of trained killers.
I know that's your Twitter,
your Twitter page off
goofing on trained killers.
Absolutely.
But like,
but they need to laugh too
cause like if everyone,
you know,
why should they speak,
you know like at me when
you make fun of someone,
right.
I'm trying to do in a way where
it's like I'm roasting them.
Like,
obviously respect that person and
it's trying to make you laugh too.
You know,
dude fucking pages of Shit that
you showed me that you have.
Like I have 50 pages of jokes
about each frame and like,
but it's like,
it's cool that I saw them.
It's ridiculous.
You have so many and the really good ones,
man,
you've got a bunch of really good ones.
Thanks man.
I'm one of my favorite one was that,
well Steven Seagal said he wants to
fight Randy couture but no witnesses just
like his last 20 films.
It was like,
I then I like bright one of them.
I wrote uh,
one of them,
I'm like,
cause I'll write something and all
of a sudden they'll get 800 retweets.
And I'm like,
like the only person who gets screwed up
from Jersey more than Frankie Edgar is
a sneaky,
like just,
and then people will just be like,
blah,
blah blah.
I'm like,
Holy Shit.
It became this fucking,
like the other night I wrote,
if I'm,
if I leave any fighters out
and you want me to roast you,
please do.
And all of a sudden all these fighters,
John Dodson,
it's like roast me,
man.
I'm short.
Well,
and then Mike piles like,
what am I too good to
be fucking roasted it?
Like all these pros were like,
I was like,
Holy Shit.
And then like 50 people started
roasting those people as well.
The,
a lot of guys have a sense of humor,
you know,
for the most part,
like Mike Pyle is a great sense of humor.
I think that it's,
uh,
you know,
for some dudes though,
they're like,
who the fuck is this guy?
Man Wants to talk to shit on me.
I do get a little nervous.
I'm not gonna,
I'm not gonna lie.
I get a little nervous when
you goof on people,
man,
they get mad.
They don't like it yet.
Well,
some,
some you get mad,
but you know,
I tried to do it in a way
where it's like respectful.
I don't mean to hurt anybody's feelings,
you know?
Yeah.
At the same time I tried to
do it in a way where like,
uh,
you know,
like,
hey,
we're just,
I don't know.
I'm trying to them laugh,
you know,
it's,
it's hard though.
It's like someone's following me and
then they lose and I want to make a joke
and I'm like,
aw shit,
I don't want them to see it.
I'm just like,
like what would you do?
A frank Trigg was in the room.
Would you tell that the,
the Frank Trigg joke,
oh,
Frederick came to my show actually.
I don't know.
I think he started following
me after those jokes.
Yeah.
I said no,
but what would I tell it to?
I'm probably,
I probably show it to them.
I wouldn't know.
I would try to gauge his reaction now
whether or not he's laughing or not.
And then base my reaction on it.
What he's going to go.
People are like what?
We talked about the jug before the show.
Oh,
about what is told.
I don't even know.
I said,
I said frank,
uh,
frank Trigg beat his wife so bad.
The Bob Sapp topped out.
And then I started making fun of SAP
and SAP started following me and then
followers started making it and I felt
bad cause followers or making fun of them
and I was like,
so then I started defending
him and then Bob cycles,
it's all cool.
It's like whenever we all toast,
when we rose Bob Saps,
I'm like,
great.
Wow.
Bob Sapp at one point in time was one
of the scariest human beings on earth.
There was a run that he had when he beat
or Nesto who's twice did he beat her?
Nesto fucking,
yeah.
Who at the time was like kickboxing man.
Yeah.
That was craziness.
And he did it just with power.
Just sheer hulk strength.
Yeah.
No,
Bob Sapp was,
it was a beast.
I mean like his nickname too.
Yeah,
that one.
There's two fights that he had.
Have you ever seen these,
Brian?
Have you ever seen it?
You should pull these up.
Bob Sapp versus Ernesto hoost because
if people haven't seen this fight,
you really don't understand how big Bob
Sapp was because he doesn't even look
like a real human.
He doesn't look real.
Yeah,
no,
it's like some CGI upset versus who?
Ernesto hoost.
She's a huge star in Japan.
After that.
I mean he was Ernesto hoost.
Is Mr Perfect.
One of the greatest
kickboxers of all time.
Yeah,
and he was like incredibly,
incredibly technical and it would just
chop chop away at you would leg kicks and
knock dudes out with head kicks,
like set you up with leg kicks and
it take you out with a head kick.
Very technical like Dutch
Moy Tai and Bob Sapp.
Just bum rushed him,
man.
Just 370 pounds with ABS.
Look at him.
Look at this video.
Look at the size of him.
Jesus fucking Christ.
That's a human look at
the size of Bob Sapp.
When he was in his prime,
he was gigantic.
He was a character in a movie.
Look,
he's getting kicked and he's
just fucking moving forward,
wailing on him.
You're talking about a guy who's just
started kickboxing like a year ago and
he's in there with Ernesto hoost
and look at how he's punching.
Look,
he's no technique or heart and muscle.
Just giant.
Can't die.
Look at the fucking size of them.
Yeah.
He's a legend.
And looking at Nesta who's just
chopping away at those legs,
trying to take them out and
SAP keeps moving forward,
trying to check his legs.
He can't even lift his legs
up there so fucking big.
Hmm.
And so slowly starting to
get homes tagging him here.
Bob Sapp is still moving forward.
I don't care how much
muscle you have on you,
Ernesto.
Who's this teen off on your face,
son.
Boom.
Big Leg kick.
Anesto oh,
we dropped some of the
left left to the body.
Look at the technique.
Beautiful left hook to the body.
Now you gotta think,
how the fuck does Bob Sapp win this fight?
How the fuck does Bob Sapp
get up and win this fight?
He playing it.
Watch this shit.
It's like a 10 minute video.
Watch this shit though.
This is where it gets crazy.
Ernesto,
who's his fucking crushing him here?
And Bob Sapp starts moving forward again
and he's holding on to one with one
hand and throws him to the ground.
I mean,
this is fight is insane.
This dude just got dropped by vicious
left hooks to the body just a few seconds
ago.
If you wanted this look at like a guy
who would be like a genetic experiments.
How bad can a guy get and
still fuck other dudes up?
You can say Bob Sapp right here,
but it's not for very long.
You can only do this
for a couple of years.
Yeah,
look,
he's eaten those leg kicks,
man.
You've got to go.
How the fuck is he still there?
Yeah,
that's insane.
Danny gets hit with that
left hook to the body.
Jesus Christ.
Ernesto,
who was just hit him with like 10
unanswered clean shots to his head and Bob
Sapp is still there.
He's even thinking about kicking him.
Just go to the end of the fight so we
can watch the end of it because in the
second round,
Bob Sapp comes back and stops him,
but he just,
you watch that first round,
you go,
how the fuck did that guy
get out of that round?
Anesto who's was teeing off on him?
He just kept plodding
forward and this is the end.
He starts fucking just
bombing these hungry,
hungry hippo punches on them.
Look at this,
look at this,
boom.
And then the referee comes
and stops it.
That's it.
That is incredible.
It's,
you know what time I got to think that
was a premature stoppage and watching
that it's a shameless guy.
It's like walking around like
getting a lot of guys in peak now.
You know,
cause those guys,
it's like the first NBA players
are the first baseball players.
There is no shame in Bob Saps career
and how he came along and when he came
along,
you can't say it's a shame cause his,
the,
the Bob Sapp days or some of the
most incredibly exciting fights ever.
His fight,
first of all,
he's fight with Minataro d there's a
reason why that fight was so excited.
Yeah.
And the reason was Bob Sapp,
I mean miniature,
it was an amazing fighter,
right?
No doubt about it.
But watching the Toro dismantle
regular fighters was one thing.
But the fact that he was going to take
on this superhuman was a completely
different entity.
You know,
and obviously it was important
that it was a minute Tara,
because Tara had such great Jujitsu,
he could handle a big dude like that and
roll with all the shots and then get to
a point and finally submit them,
which he did.
But you got to realize that the Bob Sapp
factor in that fight was the reason why
it was so exciting.
It was like,
this is fucking giant freak.
This guy that's like 370 pounds like with
a giant six pack and he's picking you
up and slamming you on your head.
He slammed him in a
towel down on his head,
like wrestling style that those,
those fights,
his fights with um,
Ernesto hoost,
the kickboxing fights and he had,
those are some of the
greatest fights to watch over.
Just ridiculously entertaining.
So that,
I don't think you can ever say it's
a shame Bob Sapp didn't come along.
You know,
cause when he was around,
like I said,
you can only stay that
big for a few years.
Right.
But what he did was just fucking crazy.
You know,
you can't say that guy
doesn't have any hard either.
You got to look at that beating
that he took with hoost,
you know,
he's just not willing to
take beatings anymore.
Yeah.
Like now he just,
he goes down and I guess he just just
doesn't have it in them to like really try
to beat the best guys anymore.
I sort of just living off his name right.
It's kind of unfortunate.
Yeah,
I think so because at one point in time
I just decided he fucking beat Ernesto
hoost,
you know,
I mean Ernesto,
who's was trying to kill him and he
survived and the referee stopped it.
Although I do do agree that it was a or a,
I believe that it was a quick stoppage.
I don't think,
I think who's going to
absorb more of those shots?
He was standing straight up.
Right.
You know,
those kickboxing matches though.
That's uh,
they're,
they're doing this glory.
They had this a world
series where they had,
uh,
they fought four times in a night.
Did you see that shit
recently?
Yeah.
Uh,
I saw,
I write about it.
I didn't see it.
It's pretty bad ass.
I hope they keep doing it.
Yeah.
What's the name?
What Cro?
Cop One last weekend.
Yeah.
Cro,
cop.
And then um,
he had
an MMA fight,
right.
He won by arm bar.
Arm Bar.
Yeah.
It looked good.
And then Tim Silvia lost.
Yeah.
He fought a issue,
right?
Yup.
Yeah.
He,
she looked good.
Yeah,
I saw that too.
it's a,
it's hard to find a good fights
outside the UFC right now.
Absolutely.
You know,
there's,
um,
like I think Bella tour puts on some
good fights and it was Strikeforce,
but now Strikeforce going away.
So it's like you gotta rely on like dream,
you know,
and dream doesn't put on that many shows,
but they,
they just had a nice one to
just see that Melvin man who,
Dennis Kang.
Yeah,
the first [inaudible].
That was the great knee to
Melvin Manhoef as a scary guy.
Yeah.
King's garden.
They're both scary guys.
Thanks.
Very scary.
He's very good.
He's,
he can,
Dennis Kang is one of those guys
that if he got it all together,
put it all together on any given night,
he could beat any given
fighter in the world.
You know,
he's one of those guys that like when you,
when you see him and he's like really on,
he's fucking sensational.
No,
he's had some really good fights.
You're real good ground game tail.
But he's had,
you know,
like some mental lapses and
shit and it's fucking hard man.
It's a crazy sport to try to do that
sport for a living and have your,
your sanity depending on it.
And then as you get older you start
reevaluating your priorities and then you
gotta to,
of rededicate yourself to something.
And
yeah,
no,
I,
I know I wrestled in high
school and college and it
was like my whole life there
was wrestling and then
when I stopped doing it,
I was like,
now what am I going to do?
You know,
that happens a lot of athletes.
Yeah.
It happens to a lot of people.
I got really lucky that I found a
standup comedy at the exact same time.
I was a stopping competing.
There's basically like a,
or it was pretty organic,
the shift from one to the other,
but I had a lot of friends
that they just would,
nothing seemed as real and
it's as fun as competition.
Yeah.
You know,
I have friends that would,
Jujitsu competition is that way to them.
You know,
for some it was the,
you know,
the karate tournament or
kickboxing or whatever.
It is like the thrill of competition,
even though there's a
lot stress behind it,
the thrill is like,
it's really hard to wrap your head around.
Yeah,
absolutely.
I mean to me,
right?
Yeah.
I mean it was like the biggest rush and
you put so much into it and then you
come down from it and you just like,
ah man.
You know,
now what?
Now what?
Luckily I got,
I had a talk show in college but
ended up getting sued for $20 million.
Yeah.
It was like a talk show in college,
cause I wrestled in high school.
That was my whole thing.
And I went to college and I'm like,
what am I going to do?
I wrestled for Suny Binghamton,
actually got a scholarship wrestle for
Hofstra and I would've burned on the same
team as Baroni and uh,
and what's his name?
And um,
J and j Hieronymus,
it's a heron,
which would have been insane.
But I went to Binghamton and I was like,
after I was done wrestling,
I was like,
what am I going to do?
I want it like,
you know,
get something going.
So I used to prank the local
television every Thursday night.
They'd be like,
let's go.
Okay.
Yeah,
cause I was cutting weight
and I was miserable.
And you need to have a
serious political combination,
but hey,
you debate and debate on my
Dick and then hang up the phone,
mark.
Goodness.
So then I ended up going down to the
station and got my own television show
called Deez nuts,
but it ended up,
the show was called Deez nuts.
Yeah.
And I invited this girl up.
People would call it and be like,
you suck.
I'm like,
oh.
And I was,
I had nothing to talk about,
kind of like now,
but I had nothing to actually,
so I was like this,
this girl came on,
everyone hooked up with named Hannah.
I want started making fun of her.
She goes back to her dorm,
people start throwing water balloons out
her and then they cancel all the shows
on Binghampton television.
Uh,
because because of my in the night
and she sued me for 20 million from
negligence cause I
didn't stick up for her,
but I didn't,
I didn't ask her to come down.
But then that was the
highlight of my life at that,
at that point.
And I go,
I want to be a comedian.
This is,
how do I get back to this
to have mental talk shit.
Wow.
Deez nuts.
I don't know man.
It was,
yes,
I was seven 17 I'm 17 years old.
Well I'm glad there's no
record of me like that from when I was
17 I would have done some stupid shit if
I could have my,
like my own internet
show when I was 17 oh,
people would play it back today.
But like,
look how douchey you were.
Oh yeah.
Well I'm just,
you know,
not that you're any douchey,
but everybody's douchey
when they're 17 absolutely,
man,
it's almost impossible.
Nappy.
It's too confusing.
And plus we were raised by our parents
and I've never met a single person raised
by parents that knew what
the fuck they were doing.
Yeah,
that's true.
Those pitches were winging it in
the 50s and mom left us three.
Whoa.
Yeah,
so that was why my
bringing me down like this.
I'm not planning,
I'm trying to get you to
know where I'm coming from.
Dude.
I'm not just gaming.
I'm not stuck.
I'm making fun of Bob Sapp.
Okay.
Sorry.
Just fucking with you,
man.
Anyway,
I was trying to talk,
talk to each other,
ladies and gentlemen.
Okay.
There's no real animosity.
There were just fuck with each other.
I was just trying to make you laugh.
So you lied about your mom.
No,
I didn't.
no.
I brought it up.
I,
it is true.
I know it's true.
I swear to God,
I was trying,
I brought it up to make you laugh.
Oh,
Jesus Christ.
That would make you laugh like ha ha ha.
Breaking it up to make you
laugh and make you laugh.
I don't know.
Some weird parallel universe.
I uh,
I haven't talked to my dad since,
I think it was seven.
Oh really?
Yeah.
So I know what you're talking about.
Sorry.
Sorry to hear that.
It doesn't bother me anymore.
I'm sure it did when I was seven.
Yeah.
Well I feel like that when you
lose something when you're young,
like a mom or a dad,
it just,
that to me that was the
inner rage in me at least.
Yeah.
That's what they say about
boys in divorce as well.
They say that like girls,
like when parents separate,
girls get sad and the boys get angry.
Yeah.
She lives and fulfill,
abandon the,
drives them to try to succeed at things
at any,
anything.
And to me now is comedy cut.
Like that's,
I love MMA so much.
But to bring it back was
because the wrestling like you,
it's,
to me MMA is professional wrestling,
like not like pro wrestling,
you know?
WBB But like that's our major leaks.
Right.
So I always root for those guys,
but I wouldn't have gotten into
wrestling if it wasn't for the rage of,
of like my mom leaving and then I wouldn't
have gotten a comedy if it wasn't for
that rage too.
So now I can bring it all back
by combining MMA and comedy.
That's funny.
Um,
have you ever done,
I mean you've been doing these,
uh,
these roasted videos now and if you ever
done anything that you wish you pulled
back,
have I ever said something?
And I said,
Bro,
I go pretty Palmer,
more guys that pulled out at
one 51 that Brittany polymer.
Right.
And,
and,
and I,
I think it hurt her feelings because I
like met her up before that and she was
super sweet and kind and I,
and I kind of like burned a bridge there
because then I felt bad because I was
only,
there was only a hearsay that she took.
She said in the video,
I like fighters.
There's a video of her on youtube saying,
oh,
fighters are cute or something,
how to pick up Brittany
Palmer or whatever it is.
So I figured if she's
comfortable enough with that,
then I could say that.
Oh well that's ridiculous.
Listen man,
if you're a girl like Brittney Palmer,
they do these questionnaire things
and I'm sure they ask her like,
how do you feel about fighters?
And I being set up is
the whole UFC outside,
right?
Oh,
walk outside,
it's going to be killed.
And Brittany Palmer and never do this.
Bruce buffer and Gober.
How dare you.
I would never do that.
No Dude,
this is like nobody wants it
set you up.
I look,
I think it's funny.
I love her.
She's a,
she's a nice kid.
She's,
you know,
but she's a girl and girls don't like
dudes making jokes about pulling dicks out
of them.
Absolutely.
I understand that there has,
but there's always gotta
be a victim in comedy.
And I know,
I understand.
I'm on your side as well.
I tried to make it nice up.
Listen,
I work with those girls and they're
very nice and the nice to me and we're
friends.
So like I would never crack jokes
about them cause I love them.
They're there,
they're sweet girls.
But I,
you know,
when you,
you say something like that,
I have to laugh.
It's funny,
I had to laugh because
there's a certain truth.
It if I,
if I like,
and that's why you're laughing.
If I would've said Kim Winslow's more
fighters have hooked up with a lot of it,
then Kim Winslow,
you would have been like,
ah,
nope.
Well,
you know,
first of all,
you just assuming that she's
hooked up with fighters,
unless you,
I do know.
I don't want,
okay.
I know of one,
so I'm not,
I'm not assuming.
Okay,
awesome.
It's very womanly and gossipy because you,
you haven't had conversations
with her about this.
No.
But you and her having talked about like,
so this is just you finding out
about her dating life online.
No,
front people from friends of
fighters or fighters themselves.
So I'm not like,
okay,
yes,
I understand.
No,
no,
I've just made it worse.
I was
going to say it,
but it's funny and that's the problem.
It's funny.
And even though it's,
it's,
it's operating on a notion that these
attractive girls would make these
attractive guys had perceived
for legal reasons.
Yeah.
Sorry about that man.
Fuck I was to represent people correctly.
Yeah,
I know.
I got another.
But uh,
my,
my point is it's still funny,
so you got to say thank you.
And you know what?
Um,
and if you're a person that's
getting mugged on like that,
you have to laugh at the good ones.
Oh,
right.
I know.
I always like my comedy.
I get,
I'm on a storyteller.
Comedy,
I tell jokes really quick one liner jokes.
Twitter is great for me.
It's like an online focus room.
You know,
I got to tell a joke
and you get 50 people,
a hundred guys at all hours of the day.
It's great.
Yeah.
You really look a Twitter writer.
It's like a,
it's funny how was styles,
comedy are so different.
You know like some guys like
Ari Shaffir for example,
he writes in like long bits,
you know,
he writes like he'll start talking about
something and he'll explore a subject
and then he'll write like this long
bit where it's like you're like,
you're,
you're like 150 characters.
You're good
hundred 30 cause you
gotta get it retweeted.
I actually figured this out.
That's so silly at 20 but can you just
hit the retweet button and it doesn't
know,
just retweet down,
sees that whatsapp,
is that really it gets
cut off or something?
No one sees the actual retweets.
Not a lot of people have
it set so that you know,
they don't see retweets.
Oh,
right,
right.
Why would you do that?
That's silly.
I find that I'm one of the most
of the cool shit from retweets.
So someone tells me something,
you know,
like if,
if somebody sends me something really
interesting and then I retweeted,
you know,
I'm retweeting it
because it's interesting.
I would,
yeah,
but if you retweeted the opposite though,
the way of putting the rt before it,
more people will see it then as then
actually just hitting the retweet butts.
So I'll start doing that.
Then we got to destroy our team.
Yeah.
Why you make a lot more people,
a lot more people and just
worked having to remember that.
And that's the actual work probably is
the fact that I have to remember it,
you know?
Yeah.
Maybe I should use like tweet deck.
What's the best shit to use?
Uh,
I like tweet Bot.
Tweet Bot.
Okay.
Yeah,
it's stressful.
And did you see Alex Jones?
Oh my God.
Oh my [inaudible] about it at a red light.
Yeah,
this is,
I guess he was on on,
well,
who show was this?
Here's Morgan.
He's trying to get it.
I'll give you the background
before he puts Alex Jones,
because Pierce Morgan
said that we should all,
we should take our guns.
You know,
we should no longer a that the second
amendment no longer applies in today's
age.
And with all these school
shootings and shit,
we should figure out how
a way to control the guns.
Well,
Alex said that he's not
even an American citizen.
He should be deported for saying such
things and challenging our second
amendment rights.
So,
uh,
Pierce Morgan,
like the slide devil that he is
invited Alex to go on his show.
And so Alex went on a show and promptly,
promptly lost his fucking mind.
Promptly.
Completely went off the deep end.
He looks like a Chubby
Madman and I love him.
You know,
Alex is my brother.
I love that dude.
Every time I go to Austin,
I hang out with that guy.
We eat dinner,
I do his radio show.
We did a little,
a cool backstage interview
and me and Brian Recently,
I fucking love Alex Jones and he's right
about a lot of shit that the documents,
but this is those.
The documents has got the documents.
Those are the documents and
play it play at a level.
But overall muggings,
stabbings,
deaths,
you those men,
right?
That woman in India to death
with an iron rod four feet long.
You can't ban the iron rods
that guns the iron rods.
Pierce didn't do it.
The tyrants did it.
Hitler took the guns stolen,
took the guns,
mounted the guns that don't.
Castro took the guns,
go.
Chavez took the guns and I'm
here to tell you it's two.
The 76 will commence again if
you proud to take our firearms.
It doesn't matter how many lemmings you
get out there on the street begging for
them to have their guns taken.
We will not relinquish them.
Do you understand?
And that's why you're going to fail.
And the establishment knows,
no matter how much propaganda
the republic will rise again.
When you attempt to take our guns
for half family and the first of all,
pause right here.
Pierce Morgan
fucked up.
He fucked up.
Pierce,
what have you done?
You let Alex Jones on your show.
You just let Alex Jones
go off on your show.
You think it's going to help them though?
I mean the first sure.
It'll help them.
You don't think people are going
to look at that and be like,
this guy's out of his mind for sure.
There's going to be that as well.
Mimicking his accident at one point
was running for president member or
I'm already flipped out and said,
we're going to this and that and that.
It reminds you of,
yeah.
Yeah.
He went crazy and then that was it.
They're like,
we're not getting this
guy from our president.
That one sound that he made
Sanches whole campaign.
It's kind of the,
don't you think that people are looking
at the message that this guy's doing is
out of control?
Rant.
Lunatic.
How did Howard Dean
never recover from that?
How would you need to like
get your shit together?
Come back.
He was like strong.
Oh.
He was up there and he was
a strong candidate man.
Smart Guy.
Governor of Vermont,
right?
Yep.
That's a little sketchy fucker.
People Vermont.
20 people up there.
Yeah,
it's me.
Come on.
Let's be real.
That's true.
We'll probably going to get tweets
from people that are in Vermont.
Dude.
Fuck you.
This is way more than 20 people.
It's amazing computer.
I know.
He likes skiing.
Okay.
I went to high school in Maine.
That was pretty amazing.
Yeah,
you were talking about that.
Where,
where'd you go?
I went to a boarding school
called the Hyde School.
It was like for a kids
who needed a kidney.
Yeah,
like alternative education.
It was really good though.
I mean
alternative education.
What does that mean?
Alternative to regular school,
which was a problem.
Yeah,
because I,
because I was,
I was hanging out with the wrong,
I was getting bullied a lot and I was
hanging out with the wrong kids and I
thought if I hung out with the,
with the tough kids that like,
then I would be tough.
But they just kicked my ass,
made me do horrible things,
awful strategy.
And then I was angry at my stepmom for an,
you know,
my dad and my dad managed
Alice Cooper in the,
in the 60s.
And he,
he has this,
he's like a Hippie,
great father.
But he was,
he was talking about pot back then,
whatever.
My mom,
you set mom,
we get along and how we do it.
But anyway,
I got sent to boarding school
for troubled kids and uh,
wow.
You couldn't,
you couldn't lie,
steal,
cheat,
drink,
have sex.
So you were like a bad kid.
You're on your way.
Not that it was your fault,
but it was my fault.
I'm not going to take,
yeah,
I wasn't bad.
It wasn't a bad kid,
but I definitely had wrong energies.
I could have been focusing on
more positive things in my life.
I think for a lot of kids,
life is like a really super complicated
puzzle that doesn't have an directions
book.
Fuck,
where am I going for most of us,
like by the time we're like,
you know,
someone's telling you to get a job,
get out of the house,
you got to get a job and you know,
move out on your own and you're like,
what did you motherfuckers teach me?
Like you didn't teach me enough
life skills to sustain myself.
Or the worst thing that they need to
teach a kid is that adults are always
right.
Yeah.
Because you assume that they're older.
They're right.
When,
how many dumb asses do
you know are our age?
You know,
age doesn't mean anything.
As a matter of fact,
there's a lot of people that,
I used to think they're really smart,
but somewhere along
the line stop thinking,
I don't know what the fuck happened,
but the,
sometimes I think I'm smart,
a word will come up and I'll be like,
what does that mean?
And it's like opens up a whole
book of things I don't know.
And I'm just like,
ah,
Jesus.
I'm like,
I got to learn some shit,
man.
No one can be smart in this day and age.
She could be reasonably knowledgeable.
That's the best you could hope for it.
There's just too much
information to the jail.
I feel like you're wired
and I'm not trying to like,
like kiss your ass or
blow you right there.
I feel like you're wired in a way or like,
you know,
so much more stuff than
like the average Joe.
Like I,
I'll,
I'll read your tweet,
your Twitter sometimes and I'm
like three o'clock in the morning,
five like,
like 12 one four and all
different subjects and I'm like,
when and then you're
touring and then I'm like,
well this guy's got two kids.
When does this fucker,
it's sleep.
Like how do I get some water?
This guy has,
you know,
like you don't,
tweeting dessert require that much energy.
Like you're always like onto some,
fuck,
you're right.
Like always send some weird
island or traveling the world.
They're like at a comedy show or doing.
I'm like,
why does he have time to do Jujitsu for
fucking two hours a day to get a black
belt?
I'm like,
fuck man,
you just do it this way.
I could do a lot more.
I'm lazy.
This is a lot of shit that I
could be doing that I'm not doing.
But I like relaxing.
I like playing pool too.
I like doing a lot of shit.
It's not productive,
but the reason I have energy to do it,
it's cause it's all interesting shit.
Like if I'm retweeting something that
I read at two o'clock in the morning,
it's because it's cool.
Like it's interesting,
weird or it's disturbing.
Maybe.
Maybe
it's,
you know,
something I think requires discussion
or thought I just got to get more
interested.
I guess that's the problem.
And more interested in science.
I'm like,
Oh man,
I think I would know stuff
if I gave a fuck about that.
I'm like,
well right now,
you know,
you're,
you and I are in different
stages of our life too.
And you're in the stage of your
life where you're trying to,
you know,
make your name as a comic and you know,
you're hustling and trying to
put shit together and you got an,
you got no time for that nonsense.
Constantly out there trying to fucking
oh hustling man.
Like,
I mean,
literally I got back from Nevada
to an eight hour trip yesterday.
I got no car accidentally back.
I did three fucking three
sixties into the fucking bang,
got home and hit the wall,
got home coach wrestling at like three
at three o'clock from my middle school
wrestling team.
I coach with Einstein,
which is a blast,
but it's like,
like the other day in practice,
it's the inner city school.
I go,
hey guys,
we have practice tomorrow.
He goes,
I can't,
I'm like,
why?
He's like,
I have court.
I'm like fucking middle
school wrestling team.
I'm like,
what is wow.
Yeah,
me or already me and Connor
hewn coached together.
Me and Connor.
Connor was the coach and now
I'm a coach up with Einstein.
Scott Epstein.
Nice.
Which is cool.
But um,
and then fucking came here.
It's like hustle.
And he's like,
but I was,
I feel like I was always hustling,
man.
Like 12 years ago I was giving out,
you know,
flyers in the street and Times Square,
begging people to come
to the comedy shows.
And that was an in laundromats performing,
you know,
and there was a was out
here and that New York City.
Oh,
you send Times Square.
Yeah.
Like here.
That's how much I'm paying
attention to right now.
Thank you man.
Just kidding.
Sorry ma'am.
Um,
the,
um,
that method of getting people in the
comedy clubs that actually works in New
York,
so many people are walking,
you know,
he can like hand them
flyers and they'll go,
fuck it.
We'll try like people that will
stand out in front of places.
I didn't,
dude.
I used to have it down packed.
Right.
See tourists look up and I'm like,
Fuck God.
I'm like,
as soon as they look up,
they're looking at wherever.
Got It.
And then I bring them
into the comedy show.
It'd be me and like the seven other
comedians that were giving out flyers.
So they look up,
they're looking for something to do
and then lying to everyone saying,
oh,
comics from MTV VH one common.
Meanwhile it's us giving
out the fucking fliers,
you know,
then try and make them laugh.
Then as soon as you got to say,
and you're like,
that's the fucker gave
me the fucking flyer.
Like how funny is he?
And I would walk the half the half the
room to the entire room because of my,
if I was the dirtiest people were like
from Oregon or whatever except for the
two chicks that were hot and I get him
back to my room and smoke weed and try to
bang them.
I remember,
uh,
in the early days of comedy,
a dude's always had fake credits.
Like you've seen this guy
and MTVs half hour comedy.
I know you hadn't,
he hadn't been on that shit.
But to say that just saying
that made a bar and you know,
Andover,
Massachusetts way through except it.
Okay,
guys been on MTV.
Let's see what he's got.
Exactly.
Yeah.
The one time I was plunging the toilets
at New York comedy club to get on stage
and the,
it was like a prom show or after the prom,
like they,
the kids to the comedy club and uh,
and all the comics left
because the PR then was late.
So Ozzy,
this Guy Ozzie,
he goes,
how much time do you do?
I'm like,
two minutes.
Can you do 45 sure.
You know,
and then,
then,
then I'm back there and
then the guy goes comics.
That's Comedians from MTV VH one.
I'm looking around like,
who the fuck is here?
They're like Adam Greenberg.
That's my real name.
Cause almost like,
so then I fucking walk up there and uh,
and do 45 minutes for these funds to
change her name from Greenberg to hunter.
Uh,
well,
because hunter is not a Douchey last name,
unless you call yourself a hunter.
It is,
it gets,
it gets tricky.
Well,
I'll tell you why.
It's actually a story there.
It's actually a real story
and it's going to be,
this is kind of sad actually.
Dude,
you bum me out again.
Fuck them for those.
At home,
we're playing.
Okay,
we're buddies joking around.
I'm not going to say fuck
me until I get into that.
Let me back up my car.
And I didn't really say is times square
or round here because I was thinking of
something that was my,
I wasn't really shitting on them.
That was fake.
So a hunter.
So anyway,
I used to work,
I work at the volunteer at the Ronald
McDonald House for three years in New
York.
I was like the head volunteer.
I'd make them all laugh and I bring dates.
Actually it was good way.
No,
but I will once in a while I bring a girl,
but not,
that was not why I did it.
Yeah,
that would be impressive.
You know,
you did a show there.
Well,
yeah,
we did shows for the kids and working on,
she would think,
oh my God,
he's so sweet.
Yeah,
exactly.
The one time though,
it backfire because,
uh,
I brought my ex girlfriend and she's like
this little girl who had like cancer.
It was like five.
She was like,
Oh,
I'm okay.
This is my friend who was,
uh,
you're not as pretty as the
girl Adam brought last week.
Oh
No.
I was like,
you fucking cock.
Oh my God.
But that was wow.
That was like one of the
best times of my life.
Those kids were awesome.
But the one kid,
his name is hunter and it's by my dad.
My Dad kept telling me that everyone
hates Jews in Hollywood and that everybody
and that I'm never going to make,
and I'm never gonna make it.
My last name's Greenberg because people
that don't want to see a big office box
office guy,
you don't see Brad Pitt.
You don't see you,
you know Tom Cruise and Adam Greenberg.
You've got to change it to something.
And so then that finally I was like,
all right,
I'll fucking change my name.
And so I was like,
you know what?
This kid is my best.
I'm like his best friend and it will
always remind me of a good time in my life
with these kids.
So I changed it to hunter.
Oh,
that's very sweet.
That's what that is a sweet story.
But,
uh,
I think you would have
been fine with Greenberg.
I think so too early in the world of
stand out it was like the dumb and crazy
and then like a month later on,
my dad was a stupid as day.
The Jews are going to be upset.
You don't claim them well,
you know,
I mean,
like I had Italian people that
were upset that my name is Rogan.
They're like,
I thought you were telling him.
I'm like,
I'm mostly Italian,
but my,
my Irish grandfather,
that's how it was.
His name,
Rogan.
That's where it comes from.
So it's like,
it's like one quarter of that
and three quarters Italian.
But the fact that they can't claim you,
well I,
I don't think they will try
to claim me Jews very upset.
You're not claiming this
claiming that my am Jewish.
So you were worried about Greenberg?
I was growing up,
my dad actually,
and anytime,
like if we get into fights,
like I should have been published,
Greenberg,
I'd be famous by now.
So I always had kind of had
that overall know hilarious.
What I did it for the opposite
reason because a rifle,
you know,
like third Reichel yeah,
right.
Ben To write cold.
It makes sense because you
know you had that name just as,
because it's the band that goes x rated
or r rated movies that to let you know
that dirty shit's about to happen though.
Yeah.
So,
uh,
that made sense.
Right.
But yeah,
Greenberg
I know,
I know.
My nickname was greeny.
Does cool nickname.
You lost your identity.
Fuck man.
I know.
Well no I don't,
I still have my identity.
I'm still happy with who I am.
It's a cute name.
Uh,
when you think about the story behind it.
Yeah.
What's,
what's and last comic
standing shouldn't so cute.
That's kind of saying they kept trying
to get me to tell that story and I
wouldn't tell it
she did for this podcast.
Well,
cause I was like,
they wanted me to be like vote for me
and then hold up a picture of the kid and
I was like,
wow.
It's like,
oh man.
I was like,
no,
I can't,
can I do that?
Like,
I was like,
I can't,
you know who's who was
producing that show?
I don't know.
I mean it was a,
I was happy it showed their life for me.
I went,
I went from feature to call feature
add a month.
He'll be here all week.
It's what is,
what is it like doing those,
um,
those boats?
Oh,
the ships.
Cruise ship.
It's,
you know what,
like I have a girlfriend,
so it kind of sucks because like
literally if you want to get,
I like,
it's like the pussy you can get,
that's what it looks like.
Him fucking bang that the passengers.
But,
but it says like,
but you could fuck the
staff and it's awful.
Like the massage girls and like the
dancers and you come in as the comic and
then they get the guests all fucking
surround you after the shows.
They're like,
ah,
that's,
that's the good part.
And like the good part is sometimes I'll
be like in Aruba or Cancun or part of
my art there and in the fucking ocean at
like noon that everyone paid thousands
of that.
And I'm like,
I'm getting paid for this.
This is fucking awesome.
So that's the good part.
And the shows 300 people every,
every single show,
you know,
and,
and five shows every two days.
And the money's fucking great.
That's the good part.
The bad part is that is that,
you know,
the same crowd comes to every single show.
So you gotta do five shows.
So like I didn't got to
do five 30 different,
30 minute shows different cause like
doing different joke,
true doing different jokes.
Right.
It's just you up there like the lady goes,
give it up for out of
butter and then you go up,
there's no like,
you know,
blah,
blah blah.
And one fund company or me
and my girlfriend broke up
for like a week one time.
And uh,
and I hooked up with it.
Like the chick that did that and I'm like,
give it up for,
for,
uh,
you know,
Jennifer,
she gets the best blowjobs in the shoe.
Shit.
It was like,
oh,
well she really was giving me
the best books on how rude.
Yeah.
All right.
Maybe it wasn't that funny.
Okay.
But uh,
no for Jennifer wasn't.
Yeah,
that wasn't her real name.
I changed her name.
Um,
she was laughing,
shake your head and be like,
oh Jesus.
Oh,
Oh Adam.
But boy they break dancers
are the ones that clean house.
Those guys get all the
fucking break dancers.
Yeah.
Cause they're with the guests all day
long and teaching him how to La on a dance
and it's all cougars.
Oh.
Oh that's hilarious.
This like a whole ecosystem on a boat.
Like the Filipinos and the Indians,
they put on the bottom,
the Italians and the top,
the middle.
They get the best view cause
they're part of the Italian navy.
It's like a whole,
it's a wow.
No.
Did you freak out when that one
boat hit the fucking rocks in Italy?
And
that happened in,
uh,
I forgot where that was,
but that was pretty crazy.
Yeah.
When those people died then the guy did
it cause he was trying to show off to
his girlfriend and then get closer
and then he didn't show up to,
well moron.
What a crazy fuck.
He and he and he like left the boat.
And I slept everyone else.
But anyway,
back to the,
the happiness,
the cruises.
It's so easy to get like
pussy on it because the guests
are all like surrounding
you and you're like the star or the ship.
And then,
uh,
I like went downstairs.
I'm like beating off angrily in my room.
Don't be angry.
Why?
Why are you beating off angrily?
Because I wanted to bang
the chicks and I'm faithful.
It's why the anger like fuck man,
shut the fuck those shakes.
Like,
I don't know.
It's really put,
shouldn't put angry and
fucking killer like that.
Just try to keep them out of your head.
I'm sorry dude.
I mean that's how I,
that's what I wished my vocab but
there is better but that's what,
those are the words going through
my head as I'm just fucking with it.
You can't get porn on the shit.
That's the hard part.
No porn at all.
No,
they blocked the porn.
It's just like,
oh,
that's so silly.
How do they block?
It just says like this act,
this website is blocked porn,
right?
Nobody has like hard copy anymore.
Everything is a youporn and
put the cruises are funny.
Like,
cause they have like special
people go on the cruises.
Like I did the boys to men crews.
Like they were on the ship rewarming yeah.
And then uh,
like Richard Simmons has a cruise,
but he only brings like,
you only brings like a
couple hundred people.
Um,
and it,
but the rest of the cruise,
if regular people to a crew
sounds like it could be madness.
And then he gets up,
starts dancing at breakfast.
All these fat people start
getting up and dancing,
but they're the ones,
not everyone is there for
the Richard Simmons crews.
So people are like,
why the fuck are these fat
people dancing right now?
And like,
oh no,
no,
no.
It's not the whole boat.
No,
it's like half the boats.
And people were like,
is that Richard Simmons?
Is that like fuck.
Could imagine
if you like,
we're going to go on vacation,
we're going to go on a nice boat.
I'm gonna sit back where a cocktail
and no one's going to bother me.
This is it.
I got a nice [inaudible].
I worked hard for this moment.
And you're sitting out there with your
bathrobe on when you're fucking slippers
and it's just a sea of giant women dance
the case
and the gay dancing in
front of you every day
the women are crying and
everyone's emotional.
They're hugging it out,
everyone's talking get out
after class and it's ridiculous.
You're transfixed.
Uh,
I've had people try to fight me like,
uh,
on the,
on the boat will not fight me.
But like one time I was on stage and
this woman was going to the bathroom and
she was a lesbian,
but I didn't know that.
So I was like,
what are you going to change
that change a tire or something.
And then she's like,
give me the microphone.
So she runs up and I'm holding it
above my head and she's jumping for it.
And I was like,
the crowds laughing.
I'm like,
well,
you can tell she's not good with Cox.
He kept grabbing the microphone.
You know what I'm saying?
Whatever sticks out in my head.
It turns out she was a lesbian.
She was,
and she was having fun.
He could go get wasted on these ships.
I mean,
you get like wasting,
you know,
so that's,
it's,
it's good.
I mean,
yeah,
right.
But when they go on vacation,
they just,
they go too far,
but you get too drunk.
Some people were just
so excited to get drunk.
They're just so excited to just
fucking a wash it away for a few days.
Oh yeah,
absolutely.
I mean,
I see people go crazy
on the three 11 ship.
Someone jumped off it.
What's a three 11 shit when like the
three 11 performed the band yet they had a
cruise that they all have their own crews
and someone jumped off the boat yeah.
To like,
cause then Jamaica like 50 miles
out or something so I could make it,
oh no he didn't.
He tried to swim 50 fucking miles.
Oh my God.
So what did they do?
He'd be like,
broke his arm and he had to go rescue him.
Oh my God.
He broke his arm hitting the water.
Jesus fucking Christ son.
Ah.
Did you imagine how bad of a feeling of,
oh my God,
I fucked up.
You would be if you were one arm in the
water broken 50 miles from shore and no,
you're such a Douche bag.
No one even says anything like
yeah,
let him fucking swim.
I saw someone get knocked out
at a bachelor party one time.
Like he said something to a girl,
bachelor party since the new girl
and the girl's boyfriend was there,
it came and knocked the dude out and the
bachelor party just like dropped them
off Miami and left him.
They're like,
well we didn't like him anyway.
So who got dropped off?
The guy who got knocked out,
I got knocked out.
Oh so he said something fucked up.
Yeah it was his fault.
But the guys just left him and so the
other guys continued on the on the tree.
Yeah.
That's kind of a win.
That's definitely a big win.
He can put that one on your record.
If you can knock a guy out and you get
to a party on the boat that he used to be
on,
but he's not on anymore
cause they pulled him off.
There had to be more than that story.
That guy had to be an Uber dude.
Yeah.
Most people must have saw that coming
and they must've been plenty of
documentation there.
See the wedding video or the I did the
comedy or the guy attacked me at the
wedding.
Yeah.
What was that about?
Uh,
what happened was they hired me to like,
do I get,
I get it.
I'm on this thing called
Gig masters were like,
I'm sure how comics now
I got to get to go on it.
But basically like you get
hired to do these gigs,
right?
So I got one one week I got hired at dude,
like these random gigs.
Like one week I got hired to do a baby
shower or I'm doing comedy during a baby
shower and like the chick was fucking hot.
It's hot Brazilian chick,
but he,
she hated her husband or something.
I'm like,
whatever.
So,
uh,
like I was like,
do you,
how the hell did you get her?
You know,
you're not gonna be able to,
she was hoc,
resilient,
but I think she hated the family.
Wanted the how to comic to Piss everyone
off because she was pregnant basically.
That's what happened.
But this other thing at the wedding,
so it feel like roast everybody just roast
every and they don't give me anything
like to go on to go on,
just go out there,
pretend you're the pre,
it's marrying people,
the minister and then,
and then start roasting people.
So I'm like,
all right,
fine.
1000 bucks.
Like do it.
So I'm like dearly beloved.
And they're both like,
she's in the army,
he's a marine and they like,
oh my God,
it's all marines in the crowd and the
backyard of Apple Valley right now.
How many people are eating 100 people?
No,
just the bride and groom.
That's it.
They're the only ones who are in,
only one is in on it,
right?
Nothing.
Huh?
That's how I show up with my,
but like my two friends who have like
sound like dearly beloved,
we are gathered here today,
blah blah blah.
And then I'm like,
you know,
I'm starting to,
and then next thing I know I'm like,
so doing material,
like how did you get her look at her tits?
Oh No,
you use it.
And the father look at her tits but nice.
He was a pretty girl.
I was like,
so then the father's looking down like
shaking his head like this can't be
happening.
This can't be happening.
So now I got it.
You're supposed to be a priest.
I got to do 45 minutes.
No Way.
It's where?
45 minutes at a wedding.
So I start going to the crowd.
I'm like,
I'm like fuck,
my friends are videotaping it.
They told me to be as dirty as possible.
They don't care.
You know?
So I'm like,
if they don't care,
I don't care.
They're the ones paying me.
So I'm like,
how many girls here shaved their vaginas?
You know,
I do that whole vagina and
like my whole vaginal piece,
he really bad to say
that I have issues do,
but at the same like 30% of the
crowd was like 20% was laughing,
right?
They were,
they were like,
oh,
this is 80% were shocked.
They didn't take the pin
and then people were pissed.
Chalk,
pissed,
laughing,
right?
So I started doing the next thing I
know I'm roasting people in the crowd.
I'm like,
well,
you know,
and have people are having a good time,
but there's one guy,
I'm like,
oh look,
it's Bon Jovi's a stupid brother.
Like,
you know,
I was like,
so he's like,
he gives me the finger like,
fuck you dude.
I'm like,
look,
sorry,
your band broke up,
right?
The Guy Charges me at the
wedding and pushes me.
He's like,
motherfucker,
he wants us to,
he fucking
landing straps to triangles or if you're
matching you offense because you're
aging,
you have a math problem.
The laughing people were laughing version,
don't even bother.
It's gonna grow back in 12 seconds.
Anyway,
I shape Alison,
Arizona by a level one eight Harley.
How's it going?
We have Bon Jovi here.
He gave me the finger.
Nice job,
dude.
When you go to a wedding wearing
white shirts and white sauce,
that's good.
I can see your muscle tone
and the stage is not good.
Your band is not going to make a scenario.
How?
Sorry you got to return those highlights.
This is what I get pissed.
Sorry.
The band broke up.
Alright.
Wow.
Thanks.
Take Care,
man.
Whoa.
Don't stop believing.
Well,
if anybody else wants to
do to get to their wedding,
let me know
via divorce party next week.
So that's edited.
That's like the last part is edited.
I do 35 minutes before I said any of
us want to do their wedding in between
that.
So then it was like,
then it was going well.
Well let's go.
It was actually getting after that.
People will kind of bonded
together that that was awkward,
but I kind of went,
well,
no.
Well definitely not.
Well,
I'm not going to,
I'm not going to go there.
It's got a lot of credit there.
It went better than that.
So then I started going and then the
mother's starts yelling at me going,
no one wants to hear about your sex life.
I,
so then I'm like,
ah,
it just gets,
then I got to do 10 minutes after that.
Finally,
the guy by your sex life,
dude,
it was so awkward.
I'm like,
one more to do clean jokes on the cruises.
You got to do 30 minutes crystal clean.
So I'm like,
I had 30 minutes clean jokes cause
there's like kids area on the cruise.
Anyway.
So anyway,
so then after that,
after that happened,
I had to wait to get my check and that
guys pacing around inside and I'm like,
and people were like,
[inaudible] people gave
me their business cards,
so do my weddings.
And uh,
this clip actually I got
contacted by a company in England.
It's going to be on a TV show in England,
like the 10 worst weddings of all time.
And uh,
they gave me another thousand.
So I was like,
yeah,
dude,
it was funny.
But uh,
yeah,
that's a Gig that you kind of take.
Ah,
it's one of those money gigs.
Yeah.
Like how are we going to do this?
A fucking,
I'm just going to do it.
But I've had so many of those kinds
of experiences where like just doing
terrible,
terrible gigs,
you know,
what do you get them?
Like someone called a club and say
we need a comedian and do something.
Exactly.
Or like,
yeah,
some bizarre comedian to just
being an asshole at our wedding.
But I used to work at,
at playboy I was the warmup comic.
That was the,
the Helis Gig on the playboy channel.
They had this thing called night calls
or it was like Jesse Jane and some other
girl customer price for hosting it at
like 15 naked chicks scissoring each other
and fisting each other.
Like Jesus,
just craziness.
Right.
It's like Brian's house
fisting each other.
I mean,
they weren't,
there was history.
So like what ended up happening,
but they would have,
like Steve o was on or had Tony,
Tony,
Tony would perform some random talk show
and like it was like the show was like,
why?
It's okay to cheat or something,
you know?
And I was the warmup comic,
so I got to do comedy while they're not
filming and it's like the crowd is like
20 people that don't want to be
seen there and I'm their view of
20 naked chicks.
I'd be more like a mixer.
Where are you from?
You know?
And they're playing music over me.
God like,
yeah,
I've had some of the worst.
It's almost like when you want to have,
but you know,
you got to do it as a comic.
You gotta Brody Stevens is the master.
Oh yeah.
Brody's the master of the warmup.
He's got it down to a science.
Dawn Buress is awesome at it as well.
Yeah,
yeah.
There's guys that get it down.
They get it down to a science,
you know?
Absolutely.
Brody would have you call and
asking him to repeat jokes,
but me and Brody used to did
the laundromats together like,
and to make you Martin
Chavez in New York City,
we used to do laundry mats
at that and Andrew Donnelly,
I remember that.
Those were like the anchor.
Donnelley had the funniest joke.
He's at the laundromat doing comedy.
He goes to the dryer,
he goes,
let me put this on no career.
There was a,
um,
uh,
episode of opiate Anthony where they
were talking about New York comedians and
the how,
how the difference between the New York
comedians and the west coast comedian
sits in New York.
Comedians are fucking brutally mean,
knew each other.
Oh yeah.
All the time.
Constantly fucking with each other.
But it's like,
it's expected and appreciated.
It's like fun.
The one time I used to play
basketball with like Kevin Hart,
Patrice O'Neal,
Rich Vos,
Jim Norton,
right.
Uh,
and I was like,
you guys were playing basketball
at three o'clock in the morning.
They called me and called me open mic.
You open mic.
They passed me the ball.
I was open.
Like,
he like Keith Robinson,
I mean all of these.
So one time I,
three in the morning,
they were playing basketball in your
clock in the morning and we'd always play
basketball.
And Kevin Hart was sick.
He lied everyone up.
He was the best one by like by far,
I mean three in the morning,
three o'clock in the morning.
We would find some,
I used to go to the comedy cellar,
I wasn't like past about it.
Hang out there and then
go play basketball.
I'd go with the Condo,
had basketball.
Right.
So what ended up happening was,
um,
one time,
uh,
Steve Marcel is a funny New York comedian.
Like he's a really funny guy.
He goes,
what if as a gang here,
what are you going to do?
We went back without our tape
recorders and then Jim Norton goes,
press play it.
They'll run.
That was like,
that is a funny,
I couldn't believe it was
like right on fucking queue.
I was like,
dude,
that's a,
that's a brain that like that I admire,
man.
I should have Norton tool areas.
He's,
he's made like single handedly trannies.
Okay.
To talk about.
It's okay to talk about your
training experiences singlehandedly.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
He's funny as hell,
man.
He's an animal.
I love that guy.
That whole opiod.
Anthony Shell.
So the best show on radio,
that's the consistently hilarious,
fucked up.
Weird and Norton
consistently makes me laugh.
He's so funny.
He's just so fucking crazy.
Yeah,
he's so off the deep end.
Crazy.
He's fun though.
That east coast sense of
comraderies different too.
This like more camaraderie.
I think amongst comics
it's east coast comedians a lot of
times it's like that's all they want is
common.
You know West Coast Comedians,
sometimes people like they're,
they do comedy but they also act,
they produce,
you know
something,
you know.
Yeah.
They're trying to get something in
show business so to just trying to be a
comic,
they're trying to be famous.
There's a lot of that,
you know,
we've all seen those
guys that go up there.
I don't even really commerce and kind
of actors and so then they just sort of
act like a comic,
which is nothing wrong with that.
I mean w
I get more mad at the
audience for laughing at it.
Like I don't get mad.
I get disappointed.
I'm like,
this is what you guys find funny.
And then I go,
maybe I'm not funny cause this
is what they're laughing at you.
Well if you never been to
comedy before and you know,
you're not like sophisticated
in the ways of the hack joke.
Yeah.
Someone could catch you.
You can just go there.
Especially when you're young.
Let's dive in.
The hack joke that bothers me.
It's like,
at least there's a joke in the hack joke.
It's like the act out,
look how talented I am.
[inaudible] scream this
method work for somebody else.
So now I'm going to do it.
You know,
guy that I came up with
[inaudible] he was,
he was ahead of me a
little bit by a few years,
but he um,
he had like a,
or was a weird act.
It was like a completely contrived act.
Like everything about him was contrived.
Like he would wear like
a jacket that had like a,
like a gas station attendant jacket,
but he didn't work in a gas station.
You know,
he would,
he had a like a look and then he had
like an act and this act that he was
piecing together.
I went and saw him before when I was a,
before I'd ever done stand up.
I was thinking about doing standup.
So I went to see some comedy punched
times and I saw him and he made me laugh.
I thought it was funny,
like a couple of things.
I thought it was really funny.
Then I started doing comedy and then
once I started doing comedy I realized,
Oh,
this kind of sucks.
Yeah.
I thought it was funny,
like I thought just like a
year ago that you were funny.
Yeah.
And then you realize all the mechanics
behind everything and you know,
like what he's doing.
It's just like really clunky,
overused bullshit.
No heart behind it.
No real point of view is kind of
a dick in real life feel like,
oh
yeah,
that happened.
That that's happening before.
Like especially,
uh,
the first guy I ever opened for
on the road after that prom show,
this Guy Jack,
this guy,
Jim and I,
he's an asshole.
He's a fucking,
his name was Jim and I asked
him and he's a white guy.
I get a phone call.
Yeah,
I got a phone call from this,
from this book,
or he goes,
guess what?
I got you booked in South Carolina,
you know,
it's going to be amazing.
But I'm like,
oh,
this is great myrtle beach.
So the next thing I know a giant
like van pulls up with this guy,
Jim and I,
and there's a black,
he had this like black puppet named sunny,
right?
Like a lifestyle.
And,
and he hit a Dick Puppet.
Like he had,
you know,
they'd say,
oh,
the guy's got to dig puppet.
He actually had a dick puppet.
Right.
Like swear to God.
So I like go in this van and we
would drive to Cassie's comedy club.
And I'm like,
oh,
we,
we're like,
we should stop off in
Baltimore or something on the
way and they're doing this
like holiday and with all black people,
he moves out the black
puppet and I'm like,
we're going to fucking die.
Like they're gonna kill him,
you know?
Wow.
But it was actually pretty funny.
Moral story is,
yeah,
he did Dick Bucket.
But he told me a funny story that
this actually goes somewhere.
He was saying that he
was driving with Sony,
the black pop at one time.
And,
uh,
he got a van and got caught on fire,
got no car accident and he like,
he was sitting there watching the van
burned down and all these kids are there
and he's like,
people that are watching this.
He goes,
oh my God,
my fucking puppet jumps inside.
Everyone thinks he's rescued this black
kid because he's carrying it and he's
carrying the head right
and it's so burned down,
it falls down and he starts
throwing his voice going.
It's okay.
I'm all right.
I know.
It was a funny story.
I wanted to share the story.
Uh,
it's probably the best
story I've ever heard.
Fuck man,
that was so bad.
I was trying to,
I was trying to and strong on that.
This is why I'm good at Twitter.
Sorry Dude.
He swung the mess,
man.
It happens to the best of us.
We've all been there.
Come on.
Okay.
I told the story last week to someone,
they were like,
you got to tell a story on the fucking,
did you follow it completely,
Brian?
Uh,
most of it.
Yeah,
I wrote it out.
Okay.
I have it written.
I will send you the story.
If anyone wants to story,
I'll email them the story
of how it really went down.
Sounds pretty important.
Yeah.
What else going on?
Can we transition out of this?
This is a part of the podcast where people
click onto the Adam Carolla podcast.
It's also available in light,
dude.
Fuck man.
Be In this year.
Uh,
I went and they have a dog.
No,
I went to AVN last year.
For the people at home that aren't freaks
is the porn awards.
What's the separate look?
Look at it.
How fucked up these two guys are.
My story and it's so casual.
So like,
yeah.
Yeah.
You want to go to AVN?
You're to go down there.
Probably go down there.
Thank you for rescuing that story,
but there's no fucking way what's right.
You know what we were talking about too.
But the folks at home,
like a lot of people like
don't know what the avms are.
Adult video news or words,
uh,
porn awards and it's from C,
like ces used to be on the same weekend
and he used to be the ultimate place
cause it'd be like the porn awards on
one floor and then the nerd awards on the
other floor that stop.
I think it was just too awesome.
I don't know.
It's too awesome.
The universe couldn't handle it right.
Last year.
Uh,
cause I was doing comedy that
week at the La Comedy Club and uh,
it was,
um,
me and uh,
I went there last year was if it was fun,
it was a little crate.
It wasn't as crazy.
Haven't,
you know,
anytime to everyone
knows about something.
It's never as good as if no
one really knows about it.
You know,
like everyone's like,
oh,
AVN awards,
everyone's all these like
guys like the paid that like,
are expecting something crazy to happen,
which never happens.
It's always like the parties
and no one knows about that.
That's like the swinger
shit goes on or the,
yeah,
yeah.
But,
uh,
the AVN awards chill.
Everybody's in bed by eight.
Yeah.
They all got their,
their toes with little cotton in between
them and they're reading the book.
They wild as fuck and electronics.
People are just on math,
raging face.
Fucking
Nia,
me and Sam and Doug Benson and end
Jason Rouse or doing a comedy show the
Thursday night at the vinyl
at the hard rock cafe.
What?
Thursday night?
What night is it?
What's the date for people listening
to this as an audio podcast?
January 17th it's an APM.
It's a part of the AVN package,
I guess you buy packages.
Like he just,
Hey,
do you want VIP to all
these clubs and parties,
you know,
one day,
two days,
three days.
And so we're doing it and it's
actually sponsored by Avn.
I guess it's going to be a vinyl though,
so it's helpful.
We're going to have a bunch of girls.
Yeah.
Do that.
That's pretty cool.
Fucking,
that's awesome.
So was there Brian's
aren't that live in it?
Nobody invited me to that show.
Gangster,
I guess,
ready to dive in.
MMA and I guess I'm DMA.
I guess it was fucking bastard.
Party's on Saturday night.
Yeah.
So it's the same weekend in Vegas.
He's like,
I'm going to have my bachelor
party in Vegas during Avn.
Yeah.
Having his own show now.
Is that what's going on?
It's just MDF talking shit.
Just talking shit with other,
yeah,
but he's keeping the whole talking shit.
Yeah.
Why not?
Just the idea of show.
Okay.
It doesn't have to be talking to shit.
I ended up talking shit
and got him in so much.
Well,
so like that's my,
my website is um,
uh,
Joe Rogan.
Dot Nat and I have a message
board on the message boards.
Shit,
talking one on one.
It's one of the forums and it's
always been shit talking one on one,
it puts,
it doesn't really mean you're
supposed to go and talk shit,
you know,
it just,
it's like,
what are you doing?
I would just shooting the shit,
you know,
like shit talking.
So it became shit talking one on one.
Like if anybody says like,
Hey,
you know,
these guys were online and
they said something and it was,
I really found it offensive and uh,
I found that disturbing than
anybody would laugh at that.
Oh yeah.
What was the forum you were on?
What was called shit talking one on one.
I'll come on you silly bitch like w
w how could you be complaining about
something that you read on?
Shit.
Talking one on one.
Take nothing seriously here.
Consider consider all that you bang,
but take nothing seriously here.
It's called shit talking one on one.
It sounds good to me,
but talking shit as a podcast,
I feel like that's,
you're really committed to that.
They're talking shit.
Yeah,
exactly.
You don't have to the whole podcast.
I totally agree.
How about just the idea of show,
what's it make a plea.
Let's,
let's try to contact ATF and
steer him towards the light.
It's not possible for him.
He's funny,
man.
I got to see him in a where was that?
San Francisco or Oregon or
San Francisco.
He was a,
when we were at that Masonic Hall theater
place and he was over at the punch on
it.
Yeah.
Was really funny.
That's fucking awesome,
man.
The punchline is awesome.
Hey FB and B,
we have to work there.
ADF inside.
Now we did at college one time
though that at Penn state.
And uh,
it was outside like 300 people.
It was like the worst gig ever.
And he's like on the flagpole telling
jokes and there were crickets in the back
and he goes,
well,
there's only so you can actually
hear the actual crickets.
Actual crickets.
Yeah.
I'm trying to think of all the
fucking crazy shows up done outside.
I did one on a college.
It was outside in the
muddle platform at night.
Oh,
you have a big fish,
big fish.
I think it's in Glendale and
it's right next to a train track.
And the whole time the owner and
the bartender just heckles you.
And then every five minutes
like a train goes by,
it's like the worst.
Ah,
one of the,
one of the worst things I ever did was
opening up for too short the wrapper
short dog in England in England that,
can we talk about it now?
Oakland?
Yeah.
No,
no,
no.
Hey Man,
meet me in Oklahoma.
Came and meet me in England.
They have totally different meanings.
I know it wasn't England,
but,
uh,
fuck
dude,
I'm on the,
I'm not supposed to do a ton of Gemini
in Monterrey and I'm driving and it says,
uh,
I thought like,
wait at the Gig and listen to
the radio station like tonight,
two shorts playing and I'm fucking,
I'm like,
I'm supposed to be there.
That's kind of weird,
right?
So I,
I like go on and they're like,
oh,
we have you opening for too short.
No one's here to see me.
It's just me swear.
And it's all like,
it's me,
Milton and,
and,
and too short.
Right.
So I'm just like cursing after every
joke that way they'll like laugh sort of,
you know,
like it doesn't ever work.
It's sort of,
yeah,
right.
Didn't even realize that you're,
um,
you're trying too hard.
You're trying too hard in
front of a black crowd.
They will not tolerate that shit.
Absolutely are white crowd would
try to be kind and work with you.
Black people paid money to
hear you talk and the fee,
you know,
funny and get the fuck off the stage.
That's,
and once they start billing,
you cannot return.
There's no pulling out of that.
Oh,
she didn't.
You don't,
you don't pull out of that fucking crash.
Get off the stage,
but lightly with the fine.
How do you do and get out of there.
Yeah.
This one.
So then,
uh,
too short goes on and he
does like three songs.
Like,
man,
you got to get paid.
You got to get paid.
It was,
you know what?
I'm not doing any more songs.
Let you guys give me
$2,000 right to the crowd.
Yeah.
There's like a hundred people there
and some people like passing around a
bucket.
Oh,
come on.
I swear.
And then there's no way I'm telling you
like that is the craziest Shit I've ever
heard.
Betty goes,
I ain't,
I'm not going to do no more songs.
Less you guys.
Can we choose
a raise like 50 bucks or something,
right?
Oh my God.
That is so funny.
So then right,
so then he goes,
all right,
you
know what I want to sperm
swallowers blow me on
stage.
Right?
Why?
I swear I swear to God.
So then these two fat white chicks go,
he goes,
I said sperm swallow,
it was best for him.
Whales.
Right.
So then then the whole crowd
starts fucking fighting,
right?
Like I have a whole crowd but like ha
like a lot of people that are throwing
bottles and finding him at each
other because the lights go on.
The cops like conscious over and it was
just one of those things where it like a
fight cop said the concert over cause we
want to get blown on the two o'clock in
the morning.
It was like it started an hour late.
It was one of those stands
or punch a cock blockers.
Okay.
If he actually got blown on stage,
do anything when it made
the story so much better.
But all of a sudden your watch that guy
rapping bone over because it was like
over.
But,
but yeah that would be funny.
If it's like an old man that
would've been sensational.
So then write a fucking,
there's like people bleeding.
It was crazy shit.
I'm just watching all this right.
The next day I come back to the
club and the owner was like,
hey man,
you would too dirty last night.
Shut the fuck.
I swear to God I'm do dirty.
What about the fucking riot
fucking happen at your club?
It was fucking crazy.
That's hilarious.
Well,
I think what he was saying is that you
know you were offensive by swearing after
every choke.
I know what a silly goose here you can
see that he was obviously he'd be like,
we have,
obviously we have other problems as well.
There was a bit of a
problem with you Adam,
running a tight ship,
imaginative to shortlist those
big girls blown on stage.
Yeah.
It was crazy.
You could have been there to watch.
That would've been a
psychological experiment,
man.
That's that to be there live.
While that happens,
that's like being in the back of a jeep
while you're watching a lion take out a
gazelle.
Looks like you watch it.
Like real nature in a
strange form right there.
Can I did too short and
too fat white women just,
yeah.
Then he was like so picky.
If you want to get
someone to blow you off.
Did you really want it first
step up.
You don't want the one who's thinking
hard but not sure and well he just made
fun of those girls.
I'm not going up now you don't.
You don't want that.
You supposed to take the first soldiers,
the ones,
but then again they could have been
like a really hot girl behind them,
but those fabric just
pushed her out of the way.
Intimidation and the sheer
bulk to get to two short.
Somebody got arrested for
getting blown during a concert.
I think it was Luke from two live crew.
It was,
it was it.
Yeah.
That's pretty gangster.
Look that up.
Find out if that's true.
Can you look that up?
Is it Luke?
Yeah.
What's the penalty for that?
Kevin?
Blow on stage.
Public display of play of
awesome.
This the greatest comic,
like if I'm having grown on stage while
I'm telling like my therapy jokes would
have been great if it was
a video of it and yeah,
couldn't get hard.
He was like,
I just don't understand
why it just never happened.
Well,
jobs happen all the time
at the comedy store.
On stage.
Yeah,
definitely onstage.
That is soaker and it's
a lot of it's guys.
That's how hard is the path there now
guys are blowing guys
now just for stage time.
That's the worst.
That was the only way to get onstage to,
it'd be dude too would do it.
There'd be dudes who would say,
hey,
you know,
I don't like it,
but you know,
part of the job,
it just fucking buckled strapped
down at Sarc Cock sucker car cloak.
Figuratively,
you know,
only literally,
I mean in my real love
making my own decisions.
That's of the crossover over poetry.
Like when that's not working,
just being a funny poet.
Have you ever seen slam poetry?
The snapping,
but when people start snapping,
I'm like,
well I can't do all the audience.
Their staffing when they like it.
They do that at pool halls too.
I don't know.
That's cool.
That pool halls,
a guy makes a good shot.
He'd do a little of that.
Let them know Dan or you tap
your queue on the ground.
You're literally killed.
Tap,
tap,
tap.
We'll let them know,
but that's some inside shit
that you wouldn't be aware of.
Sun.
I actually met my friend
who's a a porn star.
T real right.
I was like this black guy.
I'm like,
Hey man,
you and your buddy ever
double came a chick.
Isn't that kind of weird
if you have to do that,
you know like two guys,
he's like,
it just like sports.
You've got to pull your position.
Wow.
That's crazy.
Yeah.
There was a dude that um,
uh,
was telling us about this
was like pre viagara days.
This dude was telling us
it's about keeping your edge.
And I was like,
what do you mean?
Like keep your hands cause you know,
keep your heart on man because
you've got to keep your edge.
And I'm like,
what do you mean by like your edge?
He goes,
just like,
it's a mindset man mindset.
You got to keep that mindset
cause sometimes it's doing
shit you don't want to
do.
I might go like,
like Dick's touching decks.
He's like,
you know,
ah Yup.
When you do a double penetration seen,
okay,
you're not doing it in
different dimensions.
Okay.
You both inside the vagina and the reality
is when two dudes are having sex with
a woman at the same time it's,
you know,
you just use in her vagina as a
container so that you could rub dicks.
That's what it is.
You rubbing your Dick's together.
That's not sex.
I mean it is kind of sexual.
You're like holding it there,
but you just got to get off on
that dude's warm slippery deck,
that warm Dick next to your Dick
and you got to somehow or another,
it's keep your heart on it
now like when I was there,
but I'm going to Florida,
this chick that I bang on time,
it was like my friend let me bang her.
She's like Bob and you and
you do and this guy at once.
I'm like,
oh what a good kid.
So I was like,
I was trying to be a good friend.
I'm like,
you know what are,
and then I couldn't get hard.
I was like,
I can't like go think guy in the room.
And I couldn't do it because it was like,
well,
he'd probably gang
gang because you couldn't get out of it.
You're fighting it so much that you're,
you know,
you're in denial.
They bothers you so much.
And I came up the next week.
It was actually,
it was as good then I,
then I got fucked everybody after that.
It just fucking,
uh,
a big line of people.
I just blew the whole,
the whole Florida.
Well if you,
if you're like passing by those
gay clubs on Santa Monica,
there's
a lot of times where I'm like,
you know,
like these people look like
they have more fun than anybody.
Like I'm,
I'm,
I'm not in the act,
but they are,
and they look like they're
having a good time.
It's a fascinating thing.
And wonder what it was that made the
transition were gay became homosexual
because it wasn't during
the Flintstones days.
During the Flintstones days.
It was,
we have a gay old time.
So back then,
that's what we know is a cultural
point of reference back then.
Gay Men,
we're going to have a grand isle when gay.
Wonderful 10.
They were having so much fun.
It was a gay old time.
Yeah,
that makes sense.
That's what meant
Flintstones meets the front,
you know that was in the fucking song.
We'll have a gay right.
The Flintstones.
You think the song was
made for Gail time as a no.
What I mean is when did it switch,
when did it become homosexual?
When did,
uh,
when did it,
when did gay become a
slang for homosexual?
To the point where it's like
accepted as a like nomenclature gay.
It's like you know,
lesbian,
gay,
Bi,
transgender.
Like Ge is in there for gay,
you know,
instead of homosexual it's gay.
Whereas at one point in time,
but it's amazing because gay became
like the actual like common term for it
everyday of day.
Are we having so much fun that they had
the suck a cock and then it became gay.
It's one of the few names for someone
that somehow or another they just enjoyed
an incorporated to the point where
it's a commonly accepted term for it.
For Gay only.
For homosexual.
Gay is the,
there's nothing offensive about
calling a homosexual person gay.
But if you look back at gay,
gay used to mean something else.
Yeah.
And then somehow or another it became gay,
but to the point or it
became a homosexual.
But it be to the point of
it being the way to say it,
it's not offensive at all.
Gay people use it.
Oh,
I'm gay.
You know,
they,
they'll use it that way.
And it's not an offense of terminology.
It's not,
I'm homosexual.
I say I'm gay,
but it never ever got bad.
You know?
It's not like,
oh,
I'm a faggot.
You're like,
Whoa,
oh dude,
don't say that about yourself.
Don't use that term.
Right.
Don't use that thinking.
You know,
but gay is not that gay is just homosexual
to the point where it's actually on.
Like,
you know,
you could sign things,
so are you gay?
You have to like,
it's weird.
It's weird how that one got accepted.
Like it's okay.
I'm just happy that it's now like,
like during the kitchen,
I'll say to a gay pride parade,
it doesn't offend people.
That's the worst.
When you can't,
you say gay something.
Yeah.
That's like as a comic it's just
brutal and you have to like,
gays are silly and should
be able to make fun of him.
There's a lot of fun in there.
Or just or just say gay pride parade.
It's not making fun of it.
Like the joke was like I
was at the Gay Pride Parade,
uh,
at in New York who was the Puerto Rican
Day parade in the Gay Pride Parade.
Ricky Martin left 127 miles because
he's both gay and Puerto Rican.
Right.
And I'm happy.
That's very funny.
But I'm happy that I could
say that at a kid show.
It's not offensive.
It's the worst when you have to,
Oh,
you can't say gay around kids.
It's like why not?
I think it's pretty clear
that the standards for
what's offensive are changing
because of the Internet.
It's pretty,
pretty obvious.
You know,
I point a fear factor.
I'll look.
When I first started doing it too,
when when I first started doing,
it was like 2002 to what they tried to
get us to do in 2011 is a very completely
different level of acceptance.
Like they were trying to get him to drink,
come,
you know,
they,
they did it.
They drank jugs of com did that would
have never flown before the Internet.
There is no fucking way.
No,
I love the sons of anarchy and breaking
bad and decks another Dexter the kite
cable.
But I love the fact that I chose that I
could actually watch and not feel like
they're always like,
I feel like in comedy in life,
it's always that the one person,
it's never the 99 people.
It's like,
oh,
one guy wrote a letter.
Well what about the 300
people to show who didn't?
Oh,
all the one person were to letter.
It's like you always have
to paint it to that person.
And I think it's like,
oh,
so many people like,
oh.
It's like,
well,
it was anybody offended?
No.
Okay,
we're fine.
Not that everyone laugh.
It's
nobody was offended.
You know what they want to try to do is
they want to be edgy and they want to
take chances but they don't want to
fall and so then you're not at gene,
you're not taking chances.
So you'll never get ahead g and you
never going to get chances on something
like,
you know,
mainstream talk shows like the tonight
show is pretty squeaky except for,
you know what?
Uh,
Norton actually said that
his sets on the tonight show,
he,
they give him more leeway.
I did that joke on him.
I don't want to get a
bunch of jokes that like,
they're like fine,
they're getting more Norton risque,
risque,
which is great because
it's like they have to,
because otherwise I'm not entertained.
I'm not,
I'm not going to laugh
at a sitcom that like,
I know the jokes are true
written for a 12 year old
or a conservative housewife.
It's not going to make me laugh.
They,
and that is a form of programming to,
it doesn't seem like it is,
but for really stupid people it is
when you give them mundane thoughts on
mundane art and Monday and comedy in
this water down bullshit over and over
again and they accept it.
It's dulling,
it's dulling because it's like you're,
you're just watching it cause he keeps
moving and it keeps being on there keeps
being things that are,
that you could follow but
you're not getting any
satisfaction of following these
things.
So when you're watching like really
dull stupid thoughts that are being
exhibited in,
in the shows,
it's like dulling your,
your like your reality is so fucking
boring and you're so miss directed that
you're actually sitting there watching
an artificial reality that's infinitely
more boring than the
actual reality you live in.
I bet you're locked in watching this
stupid fake dad with his stupid fake
argument with a stupid fake wife,
and you're watching these two knuckleheads
going back and forth with this
artificial resolution doesn't
make any sense and the real world.
Well,
you know,
we've got to keep this
family together and like,
yeah,
that's how fuck you're breaking
people's brains with that horse shit.
When you,
you make people watch stuff like that.
Yeah.
You're pumping shit thoughts into their
pea brains and it's sloshes around in
there and everything.
Oh,
that's why I get upset when you say
the hacky conduct makes a joke and they
laugh because I think that that,
back to that of like they're laughing at
what they've been trained to laugh at,
which is bullshit.
Sometimes the laugh and just had a rhythm.
You know,
there's a,
there was a lot of comics,
especially in the 80s
that weren't funny at all.
They just had,
they would say funny in a
funny way with a rhythm.
Yeah.
And then somehow or another,
they thought that that was a word.
Some of these guys.
Yeah.
Now who like,
Oh,
I did Carson at that letter.
Yeah.
And just like a man,
the creativity,
you know,
that's the one for a lot of folks
is the most difficult aspect of it.
The creativity,
the ability to create pits,
the ability to come up with
stuff that's relevant and funny.
Brian Cowen,
I called him up one day and counselor,
you've been like kind of a
mentor to me and he's like,
oh,
someone's going to fucking hit
the rock like the cabins one day.
I'm like hell.
And I didn't get Montreal.
My manager left me,
I got thrown off last time,
whatever I was telling him and he's like,
Bro,
put your head down and write.
That's just keep working.
Don't,
and that's to me what I have to remind
myself to do is just have tunnel vision
of like don't worry about what everyone
else is doing and everyone else who's
succeeding.
And that's the hardest part for
me is to like actually do that.
Yeah.
That's why what we were
talking about earlier about,
you know,
you were like,
when do you have the time to look
at all these different things?
And read all these different things.
Well those are the things that are
interesting to me because I don't have to
worry about that other stuff anymore.
And when you don't have
to worry about like,
you know,
if they're constantly scramble and warrior
like what's going to happen with my
career?
Where am I going to be in a year from now?
Am I going to be able to pay my bills?
When that shit's out of the way,
you can just concentrate on
things that you find interesting.
And oddly enough,
I'm more productive that
way than I ever was.
You know,
in a way where I was just
trying to be productive,
you know,
and concentrating on that instead of
concentrating on the actual stuff I'm
doing.
But now,
now,
because I can concentrate on
the actual stuff I'm doing,
whether it's podcasts or writing
comedy or working for the UFC,
I can concentrate only on that stuff.
Yeah,
that's what I'm,
that's the,
that's the one thing about
like the shifts or whatever,
like the downtime to create is like,
like I've finally like,
you know,
finished two scripts.
You're going to sell those.
Sold a TV show to,
uh,
to fuel a couple of months ago.
It's awesome.
Congratulations.
Oh Bang.
If you will actually just got some cable
award for being the fastest growing
channel on cable in 2012.
They gained more,
more viewers on 2012.
They didn't take it out,
but that's how I sold it to them.
It's a lot of it.
I think the UFC,
cause it's so much fights
on great over there.
It's fucking incredible.
You Watch fuel most most days there's
fights on and it's like basically like the
fucking UFC now.
It is beautiful.
And uh,
and now I'm like producing another show,
you know,
and then working
on,
you know,
like I did Leno,
that was cool.
So this is constantly working and I'll
kind of get the enemy roasted bigger
cause I think it's like,
well this is a huge market for MMA fans
now and to have like a strict humor
site.
There's a few guys that do
like Tommy Toehold Avila.
Yeah,
he's fine.
Hilarious man.
Those,
those things are fucking hilarious.
And,
uh,
you know,
there's a few other sites that have done
like animations and stuff like that.
They're really funny people
are the memes people.
Oh yeah.
The animated Gif
make me laugh.
Or even like,
like someone over right.
A post to the thread and I'll look
down and the guy takes like an 80s,
1950s movie.
He goes,
get out,
get out with the word,
get out.
This is like,
oh my God.
It was a picture of me at the Wayans
came to Alaska to dos Santos and I,
when I'm at the weigh ins,
see for folks who,
uh,
like put it in perspective.
All right.
For me,
uh,
I'm a,
I'm a huge fight fan.
I've always been a
fight fan my whole life.
It's pretty obvious anybody sees me do
or he listens to me rather do commentary.
I don't have to fake,
like,
whether or not I'm excited about that,
that is,
um,
about,
oh,
I've always been obsessed with it.
Uh,
with the sport of mixed martial arts,
it's um,
you know,
to me it's the moment of the way in is
a really special aspect of that because
these guys,
they're going to circle around each
other and the hotels and the lobbies and
they might shake cans even they might
post for picture even they might have to
do some press shit together and they've
been thinking about nothing but each
other for six,
eight weeks,
even more,
you know,
I mean for some dudes,
so they're scheduling big
fights months in advance,
right?
And then they're standing there and
they get off that scale and they stepped
towards each other and hold their
knuckles in front of each other.
And they know that in less than 24 hours,
so a little bit more than
24 hours actually they're
going to throw down like all
this shit is coming to an end tomorrow.
And that moment right there is so intense.
You looking over at junior dos Santos,
he's a fucking killer.
He knocked Cain Velasquez down in
64 fucking seconds the first time.
They mean,
and then you see Cain,
who before that everybody thought was the
baddest motherfucker on two wheels and
it was going to be a really hard beat.
That guy,
everybody was thinking,
can't just going to put
that wrestling pace on you.
Keep shooting those doubles until you
were out and then hammer fist you into
oblivion.
And that's what he did to Jr.
But before this fight,
man,
you know,
you looked at the two of them and
there was so much on the line,
the UFC heavyweight title and the fact
that he had not cane out in the first
round,
the first fight,
and when Cain raised his knuckle up to
juniors face the same way junior does,
and they're just both stood,
stood their ground like that.
Woo.
God Damn,
there's some fucking energy in that room.
You're,
you're like,
this is going to be
some epic shit tomorrow.
The two of them just
staring at each other.
No one Blinken the two best
heavyweights on the planet,
right enough fucking throw bombs.
That's a funny video.
Funny.
Oh my God.
They took that picture
and put it on everything.
I was a,
I was coming out of women's Vaginas,
it's dying.
I was uh,
that's like,
to me that's the thing about like
the great thing about Emmy roasted.
Is that
like half to the fans are wrestlers
or did you do to people even more?
It's like I can never
get those people like,
like whatever in a room.
But in the,
on this thing that's like all these can
I see the belts are and the geese and
like I'm doing jokes that
like no one's going to get,
but those people or I mean
UFC fans like I'm like,
you know,
you know your watch too much MMA when
your girlfriend friends like to Banger and
you pass your guard and people like,
and people laugh at that
because they get it,
you know?
But if I did that on
the stage would be like,
what the what?
What's pastor guard?
What are you talking about?
You know?
So I feel like I'm speaking a language
that only see these people speak,
which is pretty cool.
You could open up my show and people would
understand about 99% would understand
what pastor gardening is.
Probably.
Yeah.
I mean that's like a,
to me that's,
that's the cool thing is that I'm able
to communicate with people that I never
thought I'd be able to communicate with
because there were actually guys would I
wrestle,
they wrestled or I did this or I train.
They train.
You know like I love UFC.
They love UFC.
What's it called again?
I don't know what happened.
Fuck man.
That out.
That is a beautiful
thing about the internet.
The fact that,
look at this
dude,
that is the funniest thing.
Pictures are ridiculous.
Beautiful thing about the Internet.
It said it kicked,
it creates,
these are really finally,
it creates some fucking,
forget what I'm saying.
Fuck it.
It creates communities.
Wrestlers can find each other.
You can find each other.
You know people that are in the comedy
or people are in the fucking whatever it
is.
Some of these people,
is that a real photo?
Pull up.
Pull that up.
The one,
how many different nutty things
that guy see that fucking guy,
the
the go bus people for.
Uh,
what the fuck is his name again?
Chris Hansen.
Chris Hardwick.
He says no,
Chris Hardwick is the
Nerdist you son of a bitch.
Chris Hansen.
Um,
Chris Hardwick's.
Good guy.
How dare you?
Um,
Krista answered how much fucked
up shit that that guy say.
I mean that guy saw like one child rapist
after another over and over and over
again.
The guys.
So unlikable you almost
route for the Predator,
right?
There's something about that
guy that like you ended up,
he's a creepy dude.
Yeah.
The guy from cheaters and hen both.
And have you do a show where
you go around Boston people?
Well,
Bob Dunkin interviewed the
guy from cheaters recently.
He said it was a really good podcast.
He said the guy was surprisingly smart.
I'm sure.
Said it was really interesting.
Oh,
you want me just putting it out there?
No,
I'm serious.
Probably was mine.
I think a lot of that
show was bullshit too.
Like big,
big stab.
It was that Bro.
Yeah.
You think so?
Um,
man,
I don't think you're
allowed to fix damage.
They would have to be like a
police record on a past podcast.
It's really ridiculous.
Really think it's fake.
Yeah.
But I think you went to the hospital.
No.
Brian calls fake and everything though.
He's right a lot though.
He gets it right.
A lot.
A lot of fake shit on the Internet.
Okay.
Don't be fooled out of hunter.
Uh,
no,
it's true.
So these videos that you're doing,
how many of those are you gonna do
and they arrested?
Yeah.
Uh,
I'm going to keep putting it out there.
I mean,
I love it.
You know,
I love doing it.
It's fun.
I wish they got more heads.
Uh,
everybody wishes they were
more successful at a monitor.
I,
everybody wishes it got more hits.
Everybody wishes their
tweets were read by more.
I know,
I know.
There are a lot of time wishing.
I wish it would pick
it a well or something.
Uh,
but yeah,
I'm going to keep doing them.
And I,
I enjoy,
I enjoy watching the fights and you're
having a reason to why is fades and,
uh,
I'm,
I'm producing a pilot now.
Hopefully the EOC will,
it's gonna you know where
it's like a Kelsey lately,
but about Mia.
Really?
Oh,
that's funny.
And it's a,
and me and a triple,
you're working on it and Joey Varner,
so we'll just go,
it's going to be great.
That's interesting because it really
is only alert couple of Emily's shows,
no comedy shows,
like there's funny aspects of shows,
but there's no strictly content.
So I think this will be good because you
do the topics in a day and a monologue
on the spike show.
The bald guy.
Yeah.
He isn't he like,
he's not a comedian or is it radio has
to be like either radio guy by the,
he think he's trying to be like,
uh,
the guy in ESPN who's trying to be like
the grumpy,
disgruntled Fan.
I watch some of this stuff.
It was a little bit like I wouldn't,
I would take a different path.
You know,
I,
I try not to be disrespectful ever.
Well that's a sports guy thing.
A lot of those soft sports guys like the
shit all over the players and they've
never played anything.
Never.
I mean I think because I mean I'm
not saying I got to go to high level
wrestling,
but I didn't get to like
high level wrestling,
you know,
what does that mean?
So you just contradicted yourself.
I won the New England's a prep
school four years in a row.
I was only the third person,
never do it.
And then I,
I won the all New England twice and
then got a scholarship to a hospital
typically by Tom Ryan.
But I didn't take it.
I went to bank so I've got to a high level
but I didn't get to a high level like
the Olympics.
The Olympics are Nash Division
One e three for like a semester.
You know,
I get to like a year.
I favor Johny Hendricks.
And that's a,
that's a different level.
What's the,
what do you think separates
a guy like Johnny Hendricks?
Like,
oh,
a real high level guy who was very
successful as an amateur wrestler.
What do you think separates him from,
from other like it like I look like I
take Rockhold is something who is very
high level wrestler but didn't but
didn't succeed UFC sort of is that no,
no,
no.
I mean what's the difference
between a guy like that and uh,
you know,
a,
a d three wrestler or a guy who's not,
you know,
not to offend any d three
wrestlers cause I don't,
I'd have to be careful with this because
some of them are talented to your tough
with some of our super top right.
72.
I mean it's like Cain car,
it's your car.
One was a dick at d two
wrestler or a d three maybe.
Then Phd too,
you know,
and some of the got Connor hewn and the
friend of mine was a d three wrestler
and you're tough as hell.
I just think d one it's just a,
it's the practices are
probably the better caliber
one.
It's essentially,
if you want to be a competitive
wrestler and you were in high school,
you look for a d one college
versus a d three college
limbic team or something.
The reason I chose Binghamton
for me was I was like,
well,
I don't want to take up my whole life
but I still want to wrestle so I don't
want to have it all year round.
I don't want to do it a couple months out
of the year and I still want to write.
But it was still my whole life.
It was like once I got there,
because it's the kind of sport
you're as good as you want to be.
It's your whole life,
you know?
So,
but I would say like,
uh,
like Matt Hamill start off with a d one
wrestler placed on the all new hurricane
went d three,
I think he wanted like two years
in a row or three years ago.
So it just,
it's a harder level,
you know,
it's a better,
but a guy like Johnny Hendricks,
why are we on this?
What was the difference?
Like,
Oh yeah,
that makes a guy,
I mean just more,
more hours of practice.
That's all it is,
you think?
I think so.
I mean,
cause some of those you got to go with,
well what testament of like wills,
how much did they love it too?
You know,
like I loved wrestling,
but I also love the attention that I was
getting in high school from it because
it was a small school
when I was a big star,
big fish in a small pond.
When I got to college,
no one really gave a fuck about wrestling.
It was like one of those sports except
for the wrestlers and a couple of
groupies.
But it wasn't like,
it wasn't like I was in high school,
so I miss being that star kind of.
And I was like,
well it's not gonna be the star.
Yeah.
Oh really?
That's funny.
What a needy bitch you are.
I hate to,
I hate to admit this,
I mean
freshing Lee,
honest and in a normal
way of thinking too,
by the way,
you know,
nobody wants to do something where they,
I mean there's a lot of people that are
doing sports at a very obscure and they
have like an inferiority
complex about that.
You know,
like you ever talked to someone who does
like an obscure sport and they're like,
they put a call out,
we play three cushioned billiards or
stuff like that and want to tell you how
awesome it is.
You know?
It's a,
it's,
it's weird.
They like have like insecurities.
Oh yeah.
Well that's the thing.
I think anytime.
I think any time you
were an athlete though,
and you'd like,
to me,
I was,
I felt like an average kid,
but then when I got wrestling I was,
all of a sudden it's
something made me special.
Right.
You know,
and I need,
then you don't rest it more to like,
to me,
I didn't feel special anymore,
you know?
Yeah.
And you know what,
that's,
I'm going,
I'm going to call genedy bitch.
You know,
I'm only talking around because
I was exactly the same way,
uh,
100% the same way.
Um,
and growing up when I
started doing martial arts,
it was the only time I ever
felt like I was worth anything.
Like,
because everything else that I had done,
I mean,
I was when I was like 15 years old
when I got serious about martial arts.
But other than that,
anything else I had done.
It was just like art,
like artistic stuff.
But I didn't know if there
was any future in that.
I didn't know.
Like I,
I thought it was a loser,
you know?
So getting good at something,
anything.
It was like what gave me my identity.
Yeah.
You know,
I think that happens for a lot of guys,
especially guys like you
or I that grew up without,
you know,
one of our family members.
You know,
I,
the good thing about wrestling though,
for me it was that not to knock a
water polo or another obscure sport,
but is that it really did
teach you cap out character.
Like,
Holy Fuck,
well I'm sure water polo
would teach a character too.
Right.
But there's a different level.
There's a different level.
The level of,
uh,
not just tenacity,
but the ability to endure hardship and
the ability to overcome uncomfortable
situations.
I know a lot of wrestlers from highschool
that fucked her body up in high
school,
man,
dehydrated themselves to the point they
look like zombies are walking around and
couldn't eat in the wrong way.
Class is getting pummeled on,
on the mat because of it.
Every day I watched these guys,
like I watched a dude who was assault
brought all his brothers like six,
two,
six one six two big giant guy.
He's like five,
five,
six.
That's I,
I'm sure I did that like,
cause he was constantly dieting
that though the way cut though.
Like they,
you know,
I would be 18 pounds one
week before the match.
Yeah.
And then it was like,
okay,
just eating to strictly salad,
not even anything else.
Yeah.
It spitting in a cup all day,
sleeping with the windows,
open the shiver off,
wait while you sleep.
Um,
putting in the heat up to like 110 and
then and then try and put as much layers
on so that I would like sweat.
And then a couple of kids my year
died from jump everything in the,
in the shower with the steam on,
they passed out fucking Christ.
So uh,
yeah that was,
that was brutal.
But that to me when,
when I used to call in
the match at the college,
the 10 matches I had,
because that's what kind of wanted
to prove that the restaurant,
the college level and
then stop in some ways.
Cause that was what was
called the prep school champ,
you know,
versus like,
but once I went out there
and you're so hungry,
you want to kill the fucking guy.
Like I'm like,
you made me fucking star for fuck.
I was getting pussy before wrestling.
I was going against the anger
and pussy with this guy again.
I'm Sam.
I was like finger down fucking hard.
Like I'm going to fucking kill
this person in front of me.
Like,
like,
cause this fucker made me starve.
I'm going to,
I'm going to kill him.
So you would get,
you would actually get like
real anger at your opponents.
I was named get myself,
my opponent,
my life,
the whole world because they made,
I was like,
fuck.
Like they made you do what you're doing.
They didn't make me do shit.
I made myself.
I was the angry,
whatever it is.
I couldn't eat.
Eating was like brutal.
I'm too logical for that.
I'd never got angry at opponents,
but I,
I,
I would get angry at
myself if I fucked up.
I would get in of myself if I lost,
but I don't remember ever really being
angry at being a dick that people take a
bad shot.
I would clap at them.
I'm like,
Oh really?
Like while you were wrestling,
I was wrestling and the
head like not even shoot,
just to fucking punch him in the head.
Like wow.
My first and my middle school
wrestling team and long island,
we were like the worst.
Like every kid was a bad sport.
We all cry and we lost and throw chairs
and like just curse out the other coach.
I didn't want to got to boarding school.
I tried that.
My first match I lost and I threw a
chair and they keep going up the team for
like,
they're like,
you made me pick up rocks for an hour.
One of the really good things about
doing taekwondo as an organized sport was
that the school that I did it with,
they were really big on manners.
They were really big on
calling everyone sir.
It was Mr. Kim and Mr O'malley.
And when they talked to
you is yes sir and no sir.
So because like they enforced this sort
of code of conduct and your in your
behavior,
it made me like,
like behave like way better in competition
than I would if I was just all wild
and willy nilly like a wrestler.
Oh yeah.
And then,
but then I got to college and then I
lost my third match that throw the chair
again,
went right back to
when did you calm down because you know,
you're a pretty calm guy now.
Yeah.
I mean,
although like Ah,
I got,
you know,
that fight I got into
it with the other comic.
Yeah.
That other comic.
That's unfortunate.
The most unfortunate thing is what he
said to you while you guys were doing it.
I took his joke,
right?
No,
no,
not even that.
Held together.
Yeah.
Could you imagine that a guy is attacking
you and he says we'd done tonight.
We dine in hell.
Yeah.
And I was like,
that's what he said tonight.
We'd done it.
How,
how drunk is that dude?
I mean he's quoting movies from the 90s.
Well,
what movie was that
tonight we'd done in hell.
Uh,
it was that gladiator.
Was it Claudia?
I didn't know that.
Cause I go,
why did you want to die in hell?
And then someone told me dying,
dying and he said he was it.
They said it was dying,
but that guy was able to
channel my rage real quick.
You know,
like that's what it,
that's a moment.
You don't,
you think I find in life that I,
I think I have something in their control.
I think I got it going.
But it sometimes that that one trigger,
well,
you know,
sometimes people can mistake a nice
person for someone who's a God that Nigga
fuck with too.
You know?
And you're always a friendly guy.
And that happens too,
especially when people
get drunk and stupid.
They just make mistakes.
You know,
alcohol is a terrible
drug for decision making.
It's amazing that we make as few shit
decisions as we do because you would
really realistically look at the Access
to alcohol that the modern adult has.
And uh,
how many people have basically
got their shit together?
It's kind of shocking.
You know,
we should all be a fucking
complete and total wreck with it.
Just a gigantic laundry list of mistakes
that you've made every time we've had a
few drinks.
Oh Man.
Like make my girlfriend,
uh,
I got banned from checking on the
cruise and I took her with me.
I was the worst,
I think.
Got a letter saying my
girlfriend couldn't drink.
Oh,
that's all sober now.
I say we,
that was an issue,
but she's,
I like the way he said it was,
that was an issue.
But I'm just immediately,
I just,
some seeing flashes of people
that I've known and that issue is,
and what that could be and
all that entails scenes in
movies with girls who are
really crazy drunk.
And Adam sitting there shaking his head,
well,
fucking beers flying in
the air plates dropping.
That was the,
that was the worst man that
would start fights with me.
She's like,
I want to take,
I want to learn Jujitsu.
What she said you did too,
and hang on my neck.
I'm like,
it's Jujitsu,
you know,
like it was once you to fuck her.
And she does want me to
find just what that was.
No,
she would get drunk and uh,
it,
it was like she'd be like,
we were in Canada.
I'm,
I'm walking home,
you know,
it was kind of,
she tried to walk home from Canada.
Yeah.
But she's,
I love her.
She's the love of my life and she's,
she's great.
She's definitely for this other podcasts.
I could do that.
No one on here.
So it's the same girl
that you're with now?
Yeah.
Two years you've been together.
Um,
she's half Filipino,
half Swedish.
Hey man,
people get drunk.
They fuck up.
Shit happens.
No alcohol is evil.
Evil drives for some
people it definitely is.
Everybody has a different reaction.
I've seen people drink and they
get a little silly and that's it.
And I've seen people drink
word to fucking shark eyes.
There are their pupils go black and
they're gone and they're not there.
You're looking at them and
they're looking right through you.
They're like,
they're in another world.
They're alerts,
they're on the Winnie the
Pooh ride at Disneyland,
fucking live,
live in their life and bright,
bright neon colors and floating honeypots.
They don't know what the fuck is going on.
I've seen it,
I've seen it and good friends.
And I know when I've talked to them
the next day that they don't have any
recollection whatsoever of the night.
Yeah.
I mean,
I know and I,
and I didn't know that really
until I started taking,
I was taking Adderall for while to like
call me down and an Ambien at night to
sleep and I was starting to have like,
like they talk about Ambien zombies.
Wow.
Glad.
Listen,
my glad you're,
you're willing to talk about that.
This is a,
this Adderall problem is a,
is a big problem.
I know a gang of people now,
it's like,
it was just only like three
a couple of weeks ago,
but now I know like six or seven people
that have had problems with that shit.
Yeah.
I mean in the descriptions that I've heard
from people like Dunkin's description
of the way it makes you feel,
this is horrific.
Your description is pretty horrific.
I don't,
I,
I just think it reminds me of coke
and I don't really like to cook buzz.
It just makes me want to do more Adderall.
Like just like I want to do more coke.
Yeah.
It didn't really change that much for me,
honestly.
It was like,
it definitely made me a little more
focused and kept me up a little more,
but it did just a little more.
Yeah.
It wasn't still taking
speed and it's just,
I know just a little more,
but I'm telling you how I felt.
I'm not telling you what you were a good
person for it maybe in like that fits.
Yeah,
I sort of think,
well that's the thing.
It was like,
I want,
when I,
if I go to a therapist and she said,
family history,
oh my mom has schizophrenia.
Oh my dad is in recovery.
My sister's in recovery,
my brothers.
Then they go,
okay,
what do you need?
You know,
that's pretty much how they do it with me,
you know?
And uh,
and so then they gave me like,
you know,
Alexa,
because I was at an OCD battle for awhile.
Like I would just like,
my mind was just not stopped going and
I would think that I was driving and I
hit somebody even though I
didn't that circled the block.
So they're like,
oh,
I just had like some high
school was the rough,
like OCD was rough in high school.
Go for it.
Like,
well,
what do you,
what do you think,
if you had a guess,
what do you think that's based on?
Is that something that comes
from stress and environment?
Is that something
that comes from me?
I mean,
I think it's genetics because like for me,
I would,
I went to go see a specialist and he
said in a one to 10 you're about a four.
And you know,
you could either go take psychotherapy
or every day you could take a pill and
then that'll,
and then I was like,
I'll take a pill,
you know,
because other than,
so I started
obsessive compulsive behavior
is based on what it was.
And then the balance of something,
lack of Serotonin in your head,
you know what that means,
you know?
So they give you like an Ssri,
is that what it is?
Yeah.
And it was,
you know,
if I've been on it for like,
well I don't know off a little bit,
but I'd say on for like 10 years,
12 years.
Oh Wow.
These Alexa.
And it's helped because,
I mean I literally,
I would like,
like whatever,
like you're not supposed to think about
is like what you think of like for me,
how,
how my mind works,
you know?
And so I would just
start like thinking that,
oh my ass is dirty all day.
Like,
even though I knew it wasn't fucking ass,
I would wipe my fucking eye.
And then all of a sudden
whenever I got stressed,
like I had a hot chick one time with
their legs fucking spread and like,
hold on,
I gotta go,
I gotta take a shower,
I got to start fucking having
panic attacks in my head.
Really.
And it was,
it was fucking brutal.
Brutal.
And it's based on a lack of Serotonin.
That's what the therapist said,
or the psychiatrist or psychologist,
the human mind is so fucking fascinating.
You know that levels of this and that
can change things for pro and con.
It's,
it's really kind of,
it's,
it's so weird because like
that's basically the quality
of your life is based on
the,
the your ability to think and move,
right?
That's it.
Those are your,
that's and your loved ones obviously,
but the quality of your life is baked
based on some shit that we don't
completely understand.
Like how many of us,
you know,
are aware of all these different
functions that are going off at any given
second that allow you to string together
the words to complete a sentence.
There's all those fucking firing going
on inside your head and we just hope it
keeps going.
We just hope it makes
sense and hope it works.
And I think it's great when there's
stories like yours that sort of override a
lot of the stories that you hear.
Like there's a lot of,
especially recently with
the school shootings,
it's been a lot of talking about,
you know,
ssrs and connecting antidepressants
to school shootings and it's,
there's a huge number.
So it's,
it's nice to hear both,
uh,
you know,
both sides of it and hear a positive
story that it took you and bounced to out.
Yeah,
it did.
I mean I definitely didn't like,
I was always worried like take it during
wrestling season cause I forgot what I
was going to lose it because my friend
had a similar things are taking,
it started losing matches
and in my mind that was like,
well if I take it because what
happens is your mind just never stops.
So if I,
if I do this and this is going to happen,
you know those commercials they have a
for like this person went like this and
then that person that and it's personal
and then the next thing and now don't be
a whatever.
You don't talking about the insurance,
I forgot the name of the brand,
whatever.
So kind of what happens here like
oh if I don't get a boner right now,
then I'm gay and I'm gay.
I'll come on to quite
loud the back of a closet,
my dad's going to be disappointed and the,
and then my kids just know on time.
What is the current thinking
on this kind of behavior?
Is it nature or nurture?
Because I know that they connect a lot
of the way a child becomes an adult,
a lot of weird shit that they
have to lack of attention,
love and certain things.
Lack of focus when kids are really young.
I wonder what it is that makes someone
develop like an aberration and the train
of thought,
like a weird thing that they can't
control and whether it is growing up in a
life full of uncertainty when
you need certainty the most.
I mean,
in order to,
you know,
when you,
when you were a child,
do you want to think that
everything's going to be fine?
But when you're a child and you realize,
well,
there's absolutely no way,
everything's fine,
everything is fucking a crazy mess
and this is life from here on out.
And that's how your mind develops.
Oh,
like before mastery matches,
like when I was the most nervous,
I would call up my dean of
my high school and be like,
ah,
I took two desserts last year.
Uh,
I,
I'm not even kidding.
I would do this.
And then he'd be like,
okay,
just go win the match.
And I go pin the kit.
It was like fucking insane.
And you just,
you needed acceptance.
Yeah.
I mean a lot of that is,
and then it's also,
but I think also it's,
I think if you could channel energies,
like there was a,
I coached wrestling and there's so many
kids out there that like if they would
just put the fucking effort like that
they put in a world of Warcraft or
whatever and to something else.
And I'm not saying anything's
wrong with world of Warcraft,
but you know,
then they would be so
much more productive.
And that's what,
you know,
my high school,
the hide was about taking kids who are
extremely negative shit going on and
taking that and channeling and deposit it.
Like you had to play a sport,
you had to uh,
you know,
talk about your feelings every
week for like a couple hours a day.
Like you have to go to seminars.
I,
I was there with like
talking about your feelings,
it talk about your issues and I was there
with like Jim Belushi sign and shares
kid was there and like all
these like it's funny story.
I actually went to go visit my sister
at the seminar one time and I was,
I was running away from the house and
being a bad kid and then the assistant,
they,
oh they had these seminars,
it,
everyone talks about their
problems and they said okay.
Lisa was like,
and my sister and my dad were
like come to the seminar.
So I like went and I'm like,
okay,
don't talk to me about anything.
I'm like a punk kid.
I don't talk anything bad.
So right away my sister,
it's her turn to speak Adam,
you don't do what the loss of your mother,
you don't deal with anything.
You and I start crying
and I'm like 12 fuck you.
And I walk out and I waited in
the car for like forties I'm like,
I'm not going back to those fucking
seminars at this boarding school in Maine.
So then I'm walking down this hill and
my dad is sitting with chair because
share,
his son went there,
share and Greg Allman,
the Allman brothers,
and,
and then she has like,
Hey,
my dad's like,
hey,
share my,
my kid's having a really rough time.
You'd say hello to one or something.
So I'm walking a 12 years old,
84 pounds and then share it goes,
uh,
Hey Adam.
I go,
hey,
share and keep walking.
I didn't even fucking acknowledge her.
It was like it.
Hey share.
It.
Just kept fucking walking.
Wow.
It's like,
fuck this.
Yeah.
Sharon kids with Greg home and I forgot
about that cause I thought like you went
to school with chastity Bono Jazz.
Yeah,
no.
And I went to,
I went with that Elijah a lie to Ahmond.
What is that kid life?
He was a cool kid.
He was like,
uh,
you know,
he was a really good guy and musician.
He was on tour with like
nine inch nails there.
I was genes that when he
was like 16 or something.
And the kids of celebrities like that.
Like your dad's Gregg Allman
and your mother share.
Good luck.
Yeah.
That's a fucking tough ride,
man.
I would,
yeah,
that's,
and that's what the thing is that,
that's the beauty of being a kid.
But the hard part about
being a parent is like,
no matter how successful you are,
like if you don't give a shit about them,
like you don't give a shit about you
that it'll come out.
It'll be pretty evident
in the way they're raised.
You're going to,
they're going to be,
you're going to be able to see how
much time this person took in spent.
It was a bad parent.
But I'm saying in general,
a lot of people are bad parents because
nobody told them how to do it right
then.
No one did it right to fam and they don't
know how to do it right and they fuck
up and they're a mess themselves.
And they try to get it
together for their kids,
but their week,
you know,
like most of us are,
most,
most people,
uh,
don't have a good,
they don't have a good blueprint.
They don't have a good
directions manual for this life.
They're just fucking making mistakes and
apologizing and trying to pay as much
attention to what everybody else's
do you want from coaching.
Now,
coaching,
wrestling,
you see the kids,
the parents come to the matches and
carrots come to practice and parents that
don't and that how the kid is such a,
you know,
it's an easy example.
Yeah.
So it's real unfortunate when you see
kids that are growing up with parents that
don't give a fuck about them.
You know,
and you'd go to a park and like,
there'll be like one kid when you're like,
where is your,
who's watching you man?
Cause like four years old and he's
just like free at the park park.
That's the hard part about these
comedy shows on the cruises,
like clean shows for little kids and kids.
Sometimes kids like,
you're not funny,
you know,
like a five year old heckles you
and I can't say anything back.
I don't want to lose my job.
You know,
I got my thing,
I looked at the kid,
I go,
look at me,
I am your future.
And then the kid just
like dead in his tracks,
like,
ah,
he doesn't know what to say.
I completely confused.
You have to deal with
five-year-old haircuts.
That's hilarious.
But the fibroids,
it's when the parent heckles that's,
I'm like,
really?
You're going to have to be on
a kid with the kid right there.
Yeah.
They had that parent heckles like,
oh,
when's the calling me
coming on or something.
And I'm like,
oh my goodness.
dude,
I always say,
listen,
come back at 11 o'clock at the adult
show and we could have this discussion.
You know,
it's just right.
But then you turn it into the dark,
the bitter coffee.
It's like such a fine line,
you know?
Well,
you know,
people think they're on vacation.
They should be entertained.
And if they don't think you're
funny and why aren't even like them.
So I'm just curious.
Speak my mind.
All right.
Pay me
$100 would be locked in
a closet every night.
But now it's like,
like the,
the cruise that I worked for,
its young and it's just
people fucking like,
whoa.
Like it's,
I mean,
not like,
I mean that's it.
The whole cruise.
I you just see a lot of single people.
Okay.
Music,
Dat,
dat like hip hop.
You see like the hip hop club at night.
I mean,
you might as well be having sex.
The dancing that goes on is like,
I mean the guy has a fucking hard on,
the girl has her ass cheeks to him.
She's just bending over and he's just
rubbing his fucking boner in her ass and
everyone's like,
and this is going on everywhere.
When I,
how many dudes come doing that?
Just dance.
Just rubbing.
Like this is good.
This is awesome.
I mean it's,
you know,
they,
I mean is that cheating
if you come while dancing?
I don't think it is.
It's a culturally accepted six dance,
a dance move somewhere along the line.
That became the thing,
the way that people dance.
So they rubbed her ass against your took.
There wasn't like normal.
That was like pretty rare,
just a few years back.
But now it's like fairly
normal when people in clubs.
A lot of fun.
By the way,
his podcast.
Thanks for having me on man.
I was,
I was actually,
I was more nervous about this,
that I was Jay Leno.
Why?
Why would you be nervous about it?
I don't,
well I don't know.
I was wondering about this in anything
because because you are like an Alpha
male.
I mean,
and it's not in a bad way,
but you're Joe Rogan and you got your,
like you have this thing
and then it's like,
I,
I never wanted to ask you for anything.
Like,
everyone's like,
why don't you have row go on?
And I'm like,
I don't want to ask him for anything.
You know,
I don't want to be that guy who,
cause I don't want to do that,
you know?
And I was just sorta like when I,
when I met you a couple
of times and I was like,
I felt like I was that nerdy
fanboy kid that was like,
Oh,
who's gonna win this one?
Who's the one note?
And then you looked like you
couldn't wait to get away from me.
No,
no,
no.
You didn't seem like that at all,
man.
I felt like I was just
annoying on your head.
It's an annoying kid
that bothered you and I,
and I wouldn't step and if I was you,
I would feel the exact same way about me.
I was like,
who is this annoying kid?
It's asking me these questions.
This is all on your own headband.
There was none of that going on.
Just start your another funny comments.
I get real simple.
And then I actually like
did Dmu once I said,
hey man,
we need this and you didn't respond.
I'm like,
great.
I fucking blew it.
Like,
and he's not going to,
this is,
I don't even look at those things.
For the most part,
they're good.
Too many of them.
CD goes out.
I'm going to all these negative comments
and then everyone's going to say,
you suck.
And then Dana White's going to be like,
you're never working.
And then it to me,
next thing I know,
I'm like all that stuff.
No,
it doesn't stop if I don't get sleep
at the sleep thing is like big.
And I had stopped taking ambien.
That was the point because I
was getting with the Ambien,
I was taking the Ambien to go to sleep
on the cruises because you lose the three
hours when you fly and
then you're on a boat.
And Paula and I couldn't sleep at night
because it shows her at 1230 at night.
And then I'm up when I'm up,
you know,
comedies,
adrenaline like when you're up,
I'm not going to bed an hour after my
five year olds are talking shit too far it
up.
Yeah,
exactly.
So then,
uh,
I started taking ambien.
My Dad,
my dad changed your last name,
bad,
says,
hey man,
take uh,
take some ambient.
You'll knock out in a second.
It's like awesome advice.
No,
just Melatonin that manage
Alice Cooper in the 60s.
That's the whole thing.
Just jerking off.
He has a great Frank Zappa bailing.
I'm gonna Start with the jail story.
Tell you about that in second.
So my dad,
uh,
says,
Hey,
take this ambiance,
I start taking the Ambien and then
next thing I know the next day my whole
Twitter there was,
was filled with shit that I wrote.
I don't remember writing.
And I started like they said like you
can get into like Ambien zombies state
the,
I didn't think that was true.
These people were just bullshitting.
I have a whole bit about it.
But being in a hotel in San Francisco
when it was on fire and all these people
were waking up on Ambien,
it was so obvious
and do and I was like,
literally I had sex with my
girlfriend one night did.
I was like,
Hey,
what time do you come home last night?
It's like we fucked.
And I was like,
Oh shit.
Like we did fuck.
And then like little memories
of us walking and she's like,
yeah,
you were great.
I was like,
the best I've ever been was on
fucking Ambien as a Zombie of a pill.
That's scary on a boat.
You could have just walked
off the side of the boat,
Zombie thing,
dude.
And I was like,
I told my girlfriend,
I'm like,
hide my keys.
If I take ambiance,
I don't drive.
But when you got to say hide your keys,
you don't drive.
Maybe you shouldn't be taking a shit.
You know what kind of
tweets to Jules send out?
I was being super nice.
All of a sudden I was like,
hey Tim Duffy,
pick fan.
When's your next fight?
And you responded.
I was like,
Todd Duffy.
I was like so big.
I know your first name.
All these MMA people like
I was like answering all my
people that tweet me like,
Hey,
thank you.
And now,
but then it was misspelled words.
It was like choppy,
choppy sentences.
The front.
It was a real problem with it.
I have,
I actually have several friends,
one a that lives on the east coast.
I don't talk to him that often,
but he's got a real problem with it.
He can't sleep without that shit.
Best Sleep I ever got.
I mean,
I had that.
That is the other side to it.
You're in a fucking,
you're in a coma.
I'm not interested.
Cma,
yeah,
I think zinc,
magnesium,
this slot,
a lot of,
a lot of different,
but you know,
then again,
my brain doesn't work
the way your brain does.
I get obsessed with shit,
but I get obsessed like a singular,
I get obsessed like,
uh,
like there'll be like something
whenever it is video game,
playing pool,
Jujitsu,
whatever it is,
and then that starts taking over my entire
day and then everybody else has just
taken up time before I
get back on the mat again.
Or taking time before I
can go play pool again.
Anytime,
you know,
that's,
I have an issue with that where I don't,
I'm not like a good balance her,
you know,
I do a lot of different shit and
luckily it just sort of organically fits
together.
But if it was just me,
I could go off the rails into
the woods on either one of them.
Right,
right.
You know,
it's almost like I need a
bunch of different things
to fixate on all the time.
That's my,
my issue.
That's great though.
Yeah.
I have a hard time just chilling out.
I can't just like,
I have a hard time.
I'm the same way.
I,
I know
I'm learning how to vacation and
I was like some new shit for me.
I liked doing it now like I'm getting,
I'm getting to the,
the idea of,
but before I go on vacation,
I have this wild,
crazy buildup where like,
I burned myself out physically.
So I don't feel bad that I'm not
going to work out on vacation.
You know?
I have like all these,
I write a shitload so that I
don't feel bad for not writing.
Yeah,
I dunno.
So that's,
that's my relaxing I've been doing lately.
The year it's watching
coal seasons of movies.
Like that's actually like,
I just been a sons of anarchy.
You Watch that?
No,
I don't watch that.
I watched it once.
I didn't like it.
He would give another shot,
fucking
talk.
Shit,
can you get me?
But like,
Olin's got my love.
I like that.
I was watched the whole thing.
I machine homeland.
No,
shut the fuck up about sons of anarchy.
God Damn,
really?
You don't even know how good homeland is.
Homeland,
it's fucking sensational.
It's one of the best
shows I've ever watched.
I'm on season two right now.
Oh yeah.
I watched all of season one and I was
not excited about this other than the
recommendations people were giving him.
It didn't seem like anything that
was really interested in and I'm like
terrorists sort of drama.
Like why?
Why do I want to watch this?
But God,
God damn is it good every
time that show ends,
I go,
damn,
that's a good show.
And it makes you realize like,
I'm really appreciate the artwork of
making a great television show because it
only comes along like once a year.
You know,
like once a year you got to breaking
bad or you gotta soprano's or something
like that.
You know,
it's like not even once a year.
Once every two or three years.
More so now I think than ever before
because there's so many of them on there's
a boardwalk empire,
which is sensational.
I just started getting into that.
There's a,
of course you got the um,
uh,
there's,
there's so many Dexter's
I don't like the extreme.
The more I watched Dexter,
that's that hope had the
funniest tweet you gave up on it.
The street.
Thanks Dad.
Hope you said,
uh,
it would be less realistic
if they had a cartoon.
More realistic of had a
cracked tooth next to Dexter.
Like walking around.
I kept picturing that next day.
Well,
I gave up on Dexter when uh,
the fuck is his name.
John John Lithgow choked
out chicken a proud tub.
It was the worst name
ever seen in my life.
So unrealistic.
I could never watch the show again.
He didn't,
he didn't really choker,
he didn't,
there was no real choking.
I'm sorry.
If you're going to fight back,
you got to try to get out of this.
What?
I'm just choking you and cutting your leg.
You would be fucking flailing like death.
It would be insane
if a guy,
if a guy is going to
choke someone to death,
okay,
there's a struggle involved in that.
Even with a chick,
you're going to realize your life
is on the line and even even,
even if it's fruitless,
there's going to be an attempt at,
it was the worst rear naked choke have
ever seen and it made me angry and as an
MMA commentator and a Brazilian Jiu
Jitsu black on that scene wasn't really,
I'm,
no,
I won't do it.
It was fake.
It was just such a,
look,
this Claire Danes,
chick who's in homeland,
this bitch can act her tits off.
She's so good.
Mrs Rogan said it best.
She said that watching her and then
you watch the other people act.
You're like,
what the fuck are you all doing?
Do you see what she's doing?
Cause this is,
I mean she plays a crazy person in
it too and it's just off the chart.
Good.
She's so good that when you,
you know,
you compare it to like crappy
acting or boring acting.
It's just like,
come on man.
It's hard because once again,
it's like people,
they want to become a famous,
they don't want to
actually study the craft.
And then Claire Danes went to like
Oxford or like England crazy school tube,
bro.
Let me tell you something.
You can't be,
you can't act crazy that good
unless you know crazy intimately.
That's true.
That's a good fucking show,
man at home when it's good show.
But you think about there's madman now,
which is apparently a very good show.
Boardwalk Empire.
You know,
I don't,
I think it was that good.
I've never seen it all.
You'd love it.
It's about a sex addict.
I didn't get if you'd like it.
You think it's good though?
Yeah,
it was great.
It's funny man.
He's an interesting cat,
you know,
to go from being the guy from,
you know Molly?
Yeah.
What was the name?
Older.
Older from the x files to being a sex
addict and then in real life he's a sex
addict supposedly yet.
But that's,
that's that whole sex
addict thing is hilarious.
It's a a funny a compulsion,
you know it's also like one of
those addictions is that like,
cause I,
I I actually went to a meeting one time,
I thought I was a second sex addict.
Why?
Because he likes girls.
No,
I went to one.
Yeah,
because why?
Because you like girls.
Well what happened was I was,
I had a girlfriend that like
I was sort of cheating on,
we weren't officially together,
but when we were together,
you know like you don't make an official
but you know you're supposed to be
together with the person.
Oh I see what you're saying.
And so you still have a
clause cause you know,
cause there,
well we never wrote anything down even
though we kind of live together now.
Right.
So let me,
so then I was like,
you know what,
I'm sorry.
Cause what happened,
I was getting,
I was actually getting a blow job and
my phone was on and the girl heard me
talking and then I go up and
heard me talking shit like baby,
you liked that.
But he also know when she called,
it was so,
it was like just a fucking,
I was like caught in the
act because I was not good.
So I said to her,
listen,
I'll go to a meeting.
I,
I'm,
I'm a sex.
I used the sex addicts like that.
Get Out.
I figured that was the best
way to like get out of this.
So I went to a meeting and
I figured those meetings,
we are creative place to get lunch.
No,
no,
no.
Well
one of the things they ask,
how many people here are
required to be heard by law?
Right.
And then like a bunch of hands go up.
Those are the molesters.
So then the whole time I'm looking
at them wondering what they did.
Just trying to figure out what they're
guilty for so I couldn't even function.
I'm probably not a molester.
Probably someone who got
caught with a hooker,
that's probably more correct.
Was trying to figure it out.
Probably do two buses.
Like street walkers.
Like,
if you're a guy and you look,
if you're a girl and you
get caught for prostitution,
it's,
you know,
there's a lot of cops
looking for prostitutes.
But if you're a guy and you
get caught with a prostitute,
it seems to me at least they'll like,
you got to fuck up,
you've got to do something stupid,
you know,
street walking,
for the guy to get busted,
he's probably driving around in his car,
picking up hookers and the cops come
up and they see you do with a wig.
Paul,
I went down to your place,
I would come off.
But if you're mad,
some people don't.
There's that.
There's some people don't want
them to know where they live,
but I mean it's like there's not a
lot of guys who get busted with that.
I would think.
I would think that more of
more women get busted then,
then guys.
Right.
Uh,
I would think,
I don't,
I
don't know anybody.
Everybody wants to with a hooker.
I've never heard of that before.
Yeah.
But so,
but that would,
that would be though,
I would think you would have to
take like sex addiction counseling.
If you got busted with a hooker,
they would say,
Hey,
what's your problem?
You're a sex addict.
Don't.
Wow.
How about the dude just
needed a blowjob and yeah.
It's so funny.
He's an addict.
It feels good.
You're addicted and things that feel good.
I know there is,
the Buzzword is undeniable though.
Compulsive activity.
You know,
when,
when people,
when someone is like one of those guys,
it's like jerking off like on
his iPhone while he's driving.
Like there's,
there's people that do that.
Oh yeah.
Oh,
the world.
The worst time I did was,
uh,
I was in Korea doing comedy for like the
troops and there's a place called like
Hooker Hill,
right?
It's called the Hooker Hill.
And it's like,
and it's all these like
girls that did the columns,
them see girls,
ladies,
these Korean hookers,
you buy him shoes for like
$10 then now your friend,
you know,
for the rest of the night,
what's the $10 and like won't tell you
that they talk to you for a couple of
hours.
Right?
Oh,
they talk to you,
but then I,
but then you can
negotiate some other shit.
So I was say,
I was in Korea and then
some girl was like,
well how much her hand
job and she's like $100.
I'm like,
I'll give you 10.
It's like,
fine.
Whoa.
Yeah.
So we'd go in the back.
Right.
So we got Asians usually so
much better at negotiating.
So we go into back and she's like,
what do you do?
I'm like,
Oh,
I'm a comedian.
And she goes,
it takes my dick and goes,
hey,
Jerry.
And I didn't,
I didn't know if she meant like
Jerry Lewis or Jerry Seinfeld,
I couldn't figure out.
That's what I'm thinking about
while getting the hand job,
you know?
Wow.
So she used you tick as a microphone?
Yeah,
it was,
it was ridiculous and no,
no,
it was,
it was fucking absurd.
I was like,
that was,
yeah,
I was young.
I was 23 Hooker Hill.
Huh?
What part of Korea is outside of Seoul?
Right.
I was going to soul.
Yeah.
I mean it's,
what is soul like?
It's gotta be a strange place.
Uh,
it's very like a lot of cheap clothes,
Hooker Hill.
But like you walk into the hook,
the bar and all of a sudden and
all of a sudden heads come up,
like walk them all,
you know,
like all of a sudden like this
random Korean hookers heads go up.
But uh,
yeah,
I know I went to Korea.
The weirdest,
I was in Bahrain doing
comedy for the military.
I did like Saudi Arabia,
Japan,
Korea,
Guam,
Cuba,
Guantanamo Bay,
Cuba.
But it was funny cause like,
but I'll talk about Bahrain.
So I'm like,
there's like this club in Bahrain,
it's like English,
British are there,
the Saudi like whatever people that,
people from Saudi Arabia
that are like sending,
because Allah isn't in Bahrain,
but he's in Saudi Arabia.
So that's where they go to like cheat
on their wives and get hookers and drugs
and drink,
wait a minute,
what,
how's it work?
Cause like as long as
they leave Saudi Arabia,
what I mean,
this is what people told me,
I'm not,
you know,
that's a good religions.
So then they would talk flight
and you just get your freak on.
So there was like a Filipino band
playing karaoke band that were dope.
They had a big hit in the
eighties or something.
So all these like Korean
hookers dancing around.
So I,
I make with one of them and I go
back to her whorehouse I'm like,
I I see,
and this is when my space first came out,
right?
So I go to this Korean whorehouse in
Bahrain and there were all these like
Americans,
like soldiers living there.
People were like,
can't make,
like Dave had moved into the whorehouse.
Right.
So I'm like,
oh that's her boyfriend living with the,
with the girls.
And then whoa.
So then I was like trying to get,
like,
I'm like,
I take one over to the computer.
They had a computer that was like a,
you know,
apple 84 or something,
you know.
So I'm trying to show you one of them
my myspace page
and I'm trying to look in the
Korean to English language to like,
no,
a comedian explained comedy,
you know,
so funny.
And then the,
then the hooker mom kicked me out.
She was like,
you can't stay unless you're
going to buy one of the hookers.
Oh,
that's hilarious.
It seems like that would be pretty cheap.
You just didn't want to pay.
I didn't want to have sex
and I don't like to have,
didn't you feel like you owed him some
money just for wasting all the time?
No.
I love to waste bringing them
over to a computer and look,
this is me.
This is me to like listen,
if,
well this is a hooker place.
We're not here to look
at your fucking resume.
Yeah,
no,
I like wasted people.
I find that funny.
I ended up beating up the
other comic on the tour,
uh,
because you beat him up,
throw him on his head.
What happened was this guy like
I'm supposed to go with Gleed.
It was one of my best friends bank leap,
but he had to bail out.
So I end up going with
this other guy from Texas.
Black comic was most racist guy.
You go would go up there and be like,
George Bush is a fucking
asshole to the military.
And he would close with like peanut
butter on his cock with dog licking off.
And I had to do his time and he kept
calling me a fag in front of all the
soldiers.
Adam's a fair,
I don't feel it goes,
it just wouldn't stop.
Why was he doing?
He was just a bully.
Like,
cause I said Eddie Murphy's movies
aren't as good anymore as they used to be
mad.
You don't know shit about anymore.
It was just giving me a hard time.
This guy,
right?
So there's an angry fellow.
So we get to Africa to boody Africa.
You kicked his ass in Africa
when the white man
kicks a black man's ass,
Africa
and I had to bail.
You brought in.
We brought them into
the country to kick it
and they shook us down and customs,
right.
You go to customs and they take our money.
It took his money.
We get to like,
it was all kind of weird.
So we go to steal your money
and I had to pay for it,
pay for him to get through customs.
Right.
Wow.
They steal like 50 bucks.
How's that work?
They were like a cost of y'all.
It's coming to the country.
Even though we already
paid with the vast boards,
we already had it all clear.
So they brought this,
you know,
that they didn't like
say give us your money.
He sold that money.
So,
so we go there and then we're in in
this Cantina with all the soldiers and I
have to,
and I'm ignoring this guy cause
he just keeps fucking with me.
Um,
so he's like,
Amen.
You're a fag.
You hooked up with trainees
in Saudi Arabia or something.
Right.
Which did not happen.
It didn't have so leave.
You would tell us.
I probably would.
So then,
uh,
so then the guy,
I like pushed it,
I'm like,
well,
let me fag.
I take his hat and push it down cause
then he comes at me and I over under and
just hip toss him on his head,
which was like,
you know,
probably had no idea it was coming.
No idea was coming.
And so I'm like,
who's the fact now?
You know?
And then the soldiers had
to break us up for fighting.
Right.
We came to entertain them.
Did you try to submit them?
No,
I,
I just was like,
you fucker like,
come on dude.
You know,
did you hit him at all when he's not
the guy we got broken up real quick,
but the,
the guy at sergeant Haggerty took
us into the bathroom and he's like,
what's wrong with you guys?
You,
you know,
on a peace keeping mission,
you're going to find Jesus.
He's a guy.
He's like,
he goes,
I'm either going to take your
money is what I did to my boys.
I'm gonna take your money or I'm
gonna Punch you in the stomach.
Right?
And we already got all our money stolen,
so we're like,
just punch in the stomach
to the sergeant punches.
Both from the stomach.
Yeah.
And then I'm like thinking to myself,
your money or punched in the stomach.
How much money?
I mean,
he punched all,
we didn't have any money on it,
so he just punched us.
That seems ridiculous.
That's what I,
that's how he treats his boys.
He said,
wait a minute.
He robs him or punches him.
He either.
Yeah,
that's benefiting him
in both circumstances.
So son of a bitch.
So action starts at home.
So the next thing I know,
I'm thinking of myself,
I'm in a bathroom and Djibouti,
Africa and I just got
punched in the stomach.
Like how many wrong turns in my life
do they make to get to this point?
You know,
that's a lot.
Did you just take it as a,
like an opportunity to work on your abs,
tighten up and let them blast away?
Go ahead,
bitch.
Adrenaline.
It didn't hurt,
you know,
Hook you in the liver.
It would been terrible.
Dirty bastard.
Did you let him make an
agreement where he was gonna hit?
You know,
he just punched in the stomach and
then that means you have a stomach.
Like what the ribs kind of,
but it wasn't a letter to this man.
I could throw a hook.
I can actually take a decent punch
like mayhem punched me like last week.
Yeah,
I heard about that.
What happened?
Well,
you know what don't say,
because then you can get sued.
Yeah.
I could give a bad interpretation because
I got a picture of a big lump on my
head.
It was an act could
have happened anywhere.
You could get hit in
the head with the media.
How do we know those
little shooting stars?
You see what if one burnt
out just as it hits you,
it just barely knocked you on
your ass and gave you a little,
that's a good point.
So that possible.
I want to know if anyone has ever
been hit in the head by a media.
I really would like to know because
I know they've landed in houses.
Wow.
That was anybody ever
been hit by a meteor.
Okay.
We gotta Google this.
I'm saying yes,
Brian,
you're saying yes,
right?
Man,
hit by and they claim they have,
but how do you know
what actually hit them?
Because he doesn't have an army anymore.
What do you think I'm going
forward before I Google it.
Yes.
It happened.
I think it happens a lot.
Coroner's report,
man killed by media,
right?
That had
coroner's report,
man killed by media,
right.
Had marijuana in his system.
Oh my God.
So this dude,
he was killed.
Oh Wow.
This is like fairly recently.
This dude was killed by a fucking media.
He was high as shit and it was walking
through the town of San [inaudible],
California,
and he got hit by a media.
Right.
Some good weed right there.
That is unbelievable.
Yeah,
that sucks.
That's,
that's what,
that's what you know,
you're having a bad day.
You know,
like you have no luck.
God dammit.
I think this is a fucking
get hit by lightning twice.
There's been a guy out there that
parody God by lightning twice these of
bitches.
No,
this was a parody.
They wouldn't tell you if a
guy got killed by a media,
if he had patna system.
It's one of those silly websites
where they're trying to be cute.
Okay,
well this one is a guy who really
did get killed by a meteorite.
Wow.
This one's not funny at all.
Make it funny.
It's impossible,
but I mean,
I'm saying it's not a
funny store story at all.
Yeah.
There's a couple of
people that can hit this.
One woman had a big Gash on her arm,
but parents should live.
She got grazed by meeting.
Right,
which is even crazier.
Think of that.
A meteorite king from another planet
flew through our solar system,
penetrated our atmosphere,
and then hit her in the arm.
Almost just grazed her
gay read second Gash.
Wow.
Well,
here's another one.
A man was struck by one killed instantly.
Damn.
It appeared.
The media had come from a direction,
a little west or south of fellow
bleakly at an angle of about 60 degrees.
It passed through a fall maple cutting
the limbs as clean as if it been a cannon
ball and struck him apparently on or
under the shoulder passing through him.
Oh bleakly from below the right shoulder,
two above the left hip and buried
itself about two feet in the soft black
ground.
Mother fucker belt,
hard to sign.
So it came through his armpit and came
out his left hip and then went through
the ground.
Mother fucker.
What a shit he's a locked at is do you
imagine it went through a fucking tree,
like a cannon ball and
then through his body,
right armpit to left hip and
then two feet into the ground.
Shit.
All in one big burst of what the fuck
just happened and is a giant hole in your
chest and you think you've been,
you know,
probably hit by with a canon or something?
Yeah.
Or attacked by aliens,
you know,
Congo load or what the fuck man,
it's probably not a lot
of people and many times
popping out.
A lot of people.
I wonder,
you know,
Oh,
here's another one.
People start.
Oh Wow,
okay.
It actually a,
a website that tracks reported
deaths and injuries from media.
Right.
Impact.
And there they have them all the
way back to 1400 BC in Israel.
It's either always the Jews,
the Jews.
Yeah,
they were,
they were keeping track even back then
at dudes that got killed by media rights.
I wonder who has God killed any of
your children with media rights?
Call this number.
You may be entitled to Shit.
That's how they were keeping track.
One day.
I'll tell God,
you son of a bitch,
I lost my favorite son.
Do a fucking media right?
Gotta be,
yeah.
Yeah.
All the way back to 18,
25 India.
Yeah,
there's a,
there's a website.
Um,
um,
just Google it reported deaths and
injuries from media or any impact.
It's fascinating to think about how many
fucking people died throughout history.
But overall I would say it looks like
it's only like a hundred people throughout
recorded history.
Maybe less,
maybe less incredible man.
But the,
the really scary things.
How many media,
right?
Showers.
There have been,
one of them,
uh,
was reported in China in 14,
90 tens of thousands of people were killed
during a meteor shower in the Shensi
province.
Imagine that shit man.
Tens of thousands of people killed
by flying rocks from the sky.
Just all the sudden Dasia
rocks are commonsense.
Slamming your fucking family.
They said the,
uh,
the similarities,
that it was a,
like a similar type of impact to
where the tongue guscott event,
that's the one that,
uh,
I think it was somewhere in Siberia
flatten this huge area of forest that
apparently exploded on impact.
Like it came and as it was coming in,
like probably either exploded just
above the ground or close to the ground.
And,
uh,
just from the,
you know,
just broke apart because of the,
uh,
coming through and just leveled
thousands of miles of trees,
just a little leveled to
square miles gone of nothing.
You look at,
pull that up Brian.
Tongue goose GFE tongue Guscott event.
Cause uh,
yeah,
just to let us know that that
shit can happen at any time.
And this is something that happened.
I think it was the night,
I feel like the 1920s
or something like that.
But I mean that's like when we started
really writing these things down and
taking pictures of them.
You know,
a couple of hundred years
ago there was no cameras.
So when things like these happened,
you know there's your,
your,
your stories about it are limited to
just people telling you what happened.
I'm like rocks and stuff.
But this tongue goose go event was
very unique in the fact that you could
actually see what a forest looked like
before the impact and what it looked like
after the impact.
And he just go,
Whoa,
what the fuck?
And then you realize that was that
nothing ball that was nothing.
That shit didn't do anything that,
I mean compared to what the,
the,
the one that hit the Yucatan
and killed all the dinosaurs.
I fucking thing didn't do nothing.
Right.
But the photos of the devastation,
those upper left photos,
Brian,
cause they're all the,
they're all black and white because
it's the 1920s the upper left.
Is there anything with the college back
then go up the Oh you son of a bitch
cracking jokes.
That's what it,
that's what the forest looked
like after it was over.
Like look at that,
look at that photo.
Just flattened like matchsticks
the entire forest mean.
Wrap your head around that photo.
No one had ever seen anything like that
where there was just miles and miles and
miles and miles and miles of flat and
trees completely pinned down to the
ground.
Flattened
from space and there could be thousands
of those hitting it anytime you read to
your kids that like a night.
Yeah.
Story.
It can.
That is my favorite.
Really set the cat in the hat man.
There motherfucker got lazy.
You only wrote two
book of that.
You know,
you like act these out cause
you can sometimes look like,
well I've not tried to scare me.
Okay.
I'm not even trying to
scare me or scare you.
It's just to me,
I wonder if you animate them.
I think it's important to
talk about those things.
Absolutely.
Bring,
bring it up just every now and then.
Just let,
just get that fucking
thought in your head.
This is a possibility.
This,
this,
this life that we live,
it was,
which is so beautiful and uh,
so complicated and so well contained in
the civilized world that we have could
end the lingo that I know
one chunk of rock from space.
It's hard to live like that though
because then you end up spending all your
money and just making all of that,
I'm serious.
I can make a decision.
Is that like fuck it,
we're going to do that.
Like,
like I was thinking if
I had a week to live,
right.
Would I be honest like,
like about how much there
cause that certain people I
don't like or I don't like
what they're doing or well,
even in this world or that world,
but don't,
I don't say it because I'd be a bad career
choice or something or I'm wondering
if I had a week to live,
if I would say it,
probably not because I
wouldn't want to be a dick,
but I,
well if you don't want to be a dick,
don't be a dick.
It doesn't matter if there's
a week to go or an hour ago,
just don't be a dick.
You can,
you know you,
it's a focus exercise.
I think whenever there's someone that's
distracting you and someone that saw
that,
you're concentrating on them for no reason
when they're really not have anything
to do with you unless they're
affecting your business or affecting,
you know,
the way you operate in your life.
If it's just you fixating on them,
just use it as a focus exercise.
Just say,
you know what?
This is obviously a test.
What advice would I give someone like me
if I was in this situation to give them
advice?
I would say,
well,
this is what you don't do.
Don't focus on that because
there's no benefited.
I know you can hate the guy unless
you got some material out of it.
Unless there's something
really funny about it
in a cup up.
For me being a comic sometimes is that,
is that those positive workshops don't
work for comedy because I think I'm a lot
funnier if I'm being negative like that.
It's focused negativity,
but it's,
but it's negative.
You know?
It's negative jokes.
It says positive but,
but if I start looking at
everything in a positive way,
I think my humor and relating to
people is going to go out the window.
Well,
um,
it will change it a morph a little bit,
you know?
Um,
but it's still possible to be really
funny and to really be really be positive.
It would just be a
different kind of funny.
I think that you're a funny guy
and I think if you're a funny guy,
you know how to be funny,
you know what I mean?
You know,
do you know?
Thank you sweetie.
Uh,
you know what I mean?
You know how to do it.
I think you would be able to do it in
any way you'd do it and what it should
represent is who you really are.
So if occasionally it's mean,
cause occasionally you're mean and the
of these mean thoughts and they're funny,
then you should fucking go with it.
That's
most of jokes.
I mean honestly
I'm a,
I wouldn't say mean spirited comment
cause I don't like to go like,
oh hope you die of aids.
You know,
there's,
there's like shock humor.
Yeah.
Where it's just what you say.
I hope you die in a car accident.
No,
I don't think I would because I wouldn't
want that person to die in the car
accident here that when he says no,
no,
he would never say that.
I don't know if I would say that.
I probably,
I,
you know,
I've gone and been on stage and
someone heckled and I'm like,
this is why I'm a pro choice,
you know?
Or something like that
right now where I'm like,
but I don't know if I would
ever like work that into like,
there's some comics they're like,
oh,
Justin Bieber dies.
I would never,
but I know it.
I know what you're saying.
It's like,
um,
as you trying to get older,
like as you're a wiser person to smart
inclination is to sort of go towards like
less altercations in your life.
Last bullshit.
Less hassle,
less people upset at you,
you know?
And it's kind of hard to do that when
you're a comedian because you have to make
fun of some idiots.
You'd have to make fun of dummies.
You see him,
you're like,
who?
This silly period.
You also,
I think have to look at the
cynical part of things I do.
Other people don't have to,
but I have to look at too,
we should,
we all we,
it was socially,
we all like have an obligation to sort
of monitor our surroundings and to keep
things from getting out of hand,
keep pet rocks from rising again.
But every now and then there's some shit
that as a comedian like your job really
truly is to make fun of these things
because they are ridiculous and we're all
going to figure out their ridiculous in
time with or without comedians like bell
bottoms,
they just did.
Eventually we go,
no,
stop it.
But comedians like that's sort of like
the role that a comic plays other than
entertainment in society is to point
out these things and to say like,
look,
come on.
This is ridiculous.
Like there's just too
many holes in this idea.
I'll give you some,
sometimes it's Wayne,
you know,
like let,
let's take NMA roasted for an example.
Like last night,
Notre Dame was w with that
losing like 35 to nothing.
Right.
And I said Cecil People's
had Notre Dame winning know.
Right.
So that's like,
okay,
ah,
that's not,
it's a funny joke,
but I love those jokes.
I love Csun people.
But then,
but then there's like,
okay,
your,
your colleague Goldberg.
Okay.
Was accused not thing allegedly
doing something right.
And it's on the MMA websites,
so it's not like I'm making this shit up.
It's on the underground.
It's on,
you know,
I mean,
maybe weekly,
I'm a junkie,
but I don't want to piss off this guy
because he's a nice guy and he seems like
he's,
if it is something serious,
you don't want to be a total dick to him.
So I try to use like Goldberg
was hopped on upper as well,
watching John Fitch fight,
you know,
so therefore the job
becomes about John Fitch.
It's still mentioned that,
you know,
still mentioning then still
mentioning the unmentionable.
Right.
So then it's like,
okay,
now I'm able to do that.
But there's only so many
times you can do that.
Right.
I've seen people say like a Joe Rogan
and a coke rage in the middle of a fight.
The reality is I've
never tried cocaine once.
I've never done it.
So I mean you can never
say you see me coked up.
I've never been coked up.
I wrote Joe Rogan's head just
exploded during the break.
That's,
that's not,
it's,
you know,
I know it sounds ridiculous,
but I've literally never
even thought about cocaine.
I really have never,
I just,
I grew up around people that fuck
their entire life up with it.
And the last thing I ever
needed was like a stimulant.
I wanted something that would kind
of center me and calm me down.
And when one,
that's one of the,
the,
when I found pawn I was like,
cause the drink would
relax me a little bit,
but a drink would also get
me riled up in a bad way.
Whereas pot like sorta
would put me in like a,
yeah,
right.
I could chill.
I could,
I could.
The last thing I wanted to be like,
no,
I did it.
I did it like three times a
once off a stripper's tits.
Cause she was like,
you want to fuck?
I said,
sure,
let's do a line of coke off my tits.
I'm like,
I'm going to do it.
I might as well.
That's the time to do it,
you know?
And then I had a girl do it off my,
well my dick one time.
Well that was pretty,
it was too,
I was hooking up with two checks.
One of them was not hot,
the other one was hot,
but it's the kind of,
I wanted a threesome.
Right,
right.
So the girl looks at my
penis as a line of coke,
which she like looks at me.
She was,
we're never going to have a relationship.
Well did she stood her ground.
She's got her morals.
She's,
she's not going to pick a guy
like you be willing to do this.
Let her snort coke off your Dick.
How dare you,
like she said then I like
the way you described it,
like a casting judgment on,
you're never going to have a relationship.
I can't even believe you're here.
I can't believe I'm about
to do coke off your Dick.
But some women's morals,
like I wasn't kidding threesome
encounter one time and I was like,
some girl was sitting on my face and
other kid was like blowing in the,
and he goes,
ah,
at least I don't cheat on my boyfriend.
And blew me.
Like she thought that wasn't cheating.
Like she really was almost like,
I was like,
dude,
I didn't want to be like,
you know,
listen,
you are cheating.
Don't stop it.
They don't want to cock block.
You'd be like,
yeah,
I hear Ya.
Yeah.
That was not the time.
Blow jobs are so not cheating.
Yes.
What,
what are you going to the
things that people do breeding,
breeding,
shoot loads.
Oh,
that's the 10 minute mark.
Um,
does anybody have anything to contribute
before we wrap this bitch up and bring
it home?
Brian,
anything going on?
He said this Friday you got to a show?
No,
no.
Uh,
next Thursday at Vegas at the hard
rock at a club called vinyl for,
during the AVN is if you're going,
it's a part of your AVN pass,
I believe.
And it's going to be me,
Doug Benson,
Sam Tripoli.
And a couple of other people.
Boom.
There it is.
Suck it.
And uh,
this Friday,
two shows at the Ice House in Pasadena,
eight 30 and 10 30.
It's a,
me and Ari should fear and
probably a couple other people.
I'll see how we do it,
but I'm trying to work out some new shit.
Yo,
you know,
I'm doing it right.
And I kind of went that way.
New,
mid to every yo all the time.
Everyday I'm hustling everyday.
I'm hustling.
You're hustling to,
and I appreciate that about you,
man.
That's one of the things I loved.
I loved when I came here and you showed
me that big file of all the things
you've written,
50 pages of the NNA jokes,
young comedians.
If this,
any fucking advice that
anybody should ever give you.
It's the advice that you got.
Put Your fucking head down and start
writing Brian Cowen and told you exactly
the right thing to do.
Just keep writing.
Just keep writing and keep and keep,
uh,
keep fucking throwing them out there.
Yeah,
it'd be nice to Brittany.
She's a nice person.
I'm mad.
I see.
Isn't that creamy?
You big meaning man,
every day I'm hustling
Adam comedian on Twitter,
but his other one,
MMA roasted on Twitter is actually more
popular than the actual human being
himself,
which is kind of weird and sad.
You should combine those two and then
no one would ever retweet your shit
because then you'd be
fucking Adam comedian,
MMA roasting the terrible
to have them all in one.
Yeah.
Everything you would say you would
limit yourself to like 60 characters.
Hey,
thank you so much for how,
thanks for being on man.
Anytime.
We'll do it again.
We'll do it again for sure.
In the meantime,
I want you to calm the fuck
down and take a yoga class.
No,
that's true.
That's very true.
You're good dude man.
And uh,
I wish you well and uh,
I think you've got a bright future
in this crazy standup business.
Thank you.
Your hustle and you're out there
making it happened bitches.
So,
um,
again,
that's a,
this,
this a Friday two shows,
eight 30 and 10 30 at the Ice House.
Go to Icehouse,
comedy.com.
Uh,
thanks to Tim for sponsor and our podcast.
If you go to rogan.ting.com you will save
25 bucks off one of their super groovy
android phones.
They have the Samsung Galaxy note
to which I will eventually get a,
once I get some time on my hands,
I'm going to pick up one of those.
I can't live with it any longer.
I have too much envy for that big screen.
I need some loving,
some big screen.
Love Him,
uh,
to tomorrow we will have a all things,
hopefully if a Dunkin is feeling good,
I will have Dr.
Trust will come on and give us an update
on his health and all things in the
universe and his unique perspective.
And then Thursday we'll
have the great Ari fear.
All right.
You fucks get it to oh Neil
degrasse Tyson this week as well.
Trying to figure out when to fit him in.
Uh,
when did,
when he can do it and we could do it,
but uh,
that's going to happen as well.
So the God of science will join us.
We're gonna,
we're gonna fucking keep this bitch
role until the wheels fall off.
All right.
See You freaked him.
Bye.